Do you think other people think that you're the Messiah?
I came out of a conference speaking, and when I walked out the door,
this mad lady comes running up to me and tries to kidnap me.
What?
Yeah.
My job is to share a truth that everyone's been told is not real.
It was 19 years ago, on January the 8th of 2007.
I was down and out and lost everything.
Lost my home, and I'm having to apply for free lunch for my kids.
Sick with Crohn's disease.
And if anybody has Crohn's, knows how bad that is.
You know, you're in the restroom 10 times a day.
I was it 20 times a day at that point.
In January of 2007, while fishing with friends in North Carolina,
Chris Bledsoe witnessed a series of bright, intelligently moving orbs in the sky.
That moment doesn't end.
It starts a series of unexpected,
and seemingly miraculous events.
And then my Crohn's was gone.
I had no more sickness.
In the days and weeks that follow, the phenomena continue.
The lights appear again and again,
sometimes at a distance,
sometimes directly over his home.
He reports numerous encounters that don't resemble crafts, lights, or UFOs at all.
But what he describes as a luminous, feminine presence,
deeply unsettling in its art,
is an archetypal familiarity.
Her communication seems to go beyond the cliches and platitudes of normal contact experiences.
They touch on humanity's deep moral decay.
Cycles of civilizational collapse, judgment, the apocalypse, and renewal.
They revolve around humanity reaching a threshold.
I came back excited to tell it.
That's when the next five years of darkness, I talk about in my book,
started.
His UFO experiences only serve to make him more of a pariah
in his local community of Fayetteville, North Carolina,
where fundamentalist Christianity is the only way,
and anything paranormal is considered demonic.
NASA and the CIA show up at Bledsoe's door.
And not just anybody at NASA and the CIA.
I'm talking about a high-level NASA mission controller
who has worked on launches at Cape Canaveral
since the 2000s.
Challenger missions in the 80s.
And he said, I was at the dinner table with the president
and handed me that.
He said that?
Yeah.
Whoa.
And this, yeah.
Scientists, military, and other intelligence officials
follow suit.
They grill Bledsoe on his experiences.
Some imply that certain dates and symbols he's given by the lady
align with things they're already monitoring
and have seen from other authoritative sources.
So they have like a scientific model of how these angels,
angels work at NASA.
They know a lot more than we know than we think they do.
I personally don't know what Chris Bledsoe experienced
and continues to experience to this day.
But I know that his story doesn't sit
at the edge of history forever.
It's either going to collapse under scrutiny
or force us to redraw the map.
In this special episode of American Alchemy,
we have a markedly different conversation
than the one that Chris Bledsoe is used to having.
He took you to Zanesville, Ohio, where you recovered
a little piece of metal?
Yeah.
Do you know who's from Zanesville, Ohio?
Yeah, I do.
T. Townsend Brown, right?
What?
Instead of just retelling his story,
we make some pretty mind-blowing connections from it.
Ones involving secret societies with access to time travel,
anti-gravity experiments done in mid-century America,
space metal with curious properties that interact
with consciousness in weird ways.
What exists on the dark side of the moon?
And what the world will look like in the next decade?
So without further ado, sit back, relax,
and prepare to ascend into the astral plane
with this week's American Alchemist, Christopher Bledsoe.
This has been a long time coming.
I'm here with Chris Bledsoe,
who many call kind of a super-experiencer
because I was just rereading your book, UFO of God,
and your life is really just remarkable.
You've had all these incredible, deep experiences,
and I want to talk about those experiences.
But I also want to talk,
because your story is well-known at this point.
I also want to talk about some of the deeper philosophies
that you've kind of come into based on your experiences
and maybe have kind of a metaphysical conversation.
But I want to start with this very interesting discussion
that we just kind of sparked up as you were walking in,
which is you have this golden pin on your jacket.
What is that pin?
Well,
that pin was given me
by someone everybody has read about, right?
Down at Cape Canaveral, without saying names.
Okay.
And it signifies being off-planet.
So from what I'm told,
the people that get these have been in space before.
So astronauts, pretty much.
Right, right.
And why do you think this person gave that pin to you?
At the time, I had no clue.
I had no clue other than what they were telling me.
It involved taking me into the astronaut crew quarters
and going through a whole thing,
because I was, in other words,
when this thing first happened,
this person from NASA came to my house with a backpack
and a whole lot of credentials
that had everything from Area 51 to the CIA
and all that combined, NASA.
And he tested the whole thing,
tested the whole family with metal.
He put a piece of metal in my hand.
I was the last one to be tested.
So all my, four of my kids and my wife,
they all went into this one room.
So she got Ryan.
He got Ryan as the first one and kind of made it secret.
He took Ryan into a room, tested him,
and said, now you go get the next person, but don't tell them.
So he went out and got each person in the family,
tested them with this metal.
They brought me in last.
And I had no idea what I was doing.
I sat down on the edge of the bed.
It was in Ryan's room.
And he put this piece of metal right here.
And I said, what do you think of that?
I said, well, it looks like a piece of aluminum,
like a postage stamp.
Size, that size, thin.
Was it light?
Very light, yeah.
It was kind of a dull gray.
It wasn't like shiny.
It was aluminum of some sort.
And he reaches in his backpack
and pulls out another piece of metal that was different.
And it was like aluminum foil.
Looked like foil.
And it wasn't creased.
You couldn't crease it, but it would wrinkle,
but it would hold back out.
But it wouldn't crease.
You couldn't crease it.
You could, it would kind of roll up and then straighten out.
But when he put that in this hand,
it somehow or another created this current
that went through where it was communicating.
This part of the metal was communicating
with that part of the metal.
And when that happened,
it caused me to, my eyes to roll back.
And he reached up and snatched it out of my hand real quick
and said, why you?
This is in the book, by the way.
And I had no idea what happened.
He said, why you this close?
I said, excuse me, what do you mean, what I mean?
He said, well, I would have known you were lying
about being taken if you hadn't had a reaction to this.
And he said, I've only ever seen two others
and they were nothing like yours.
That's what he told me.
So that started the next two, three years studying with them.
And I'm being kind to my friend without saying his name,
but you know who I'm talking about.
I know who you're talking about.
Can I say who it is?
Because it's, I think it's Tim Taylor,
who's a NASA mission controller,
who, yeah, his name is now sort of out there.
And yeah, we should definitely be respectful to him
as somebody who doesn't.
Maybe want to do public interviews himself,
but I think he's put himself out there enough to, you know.
So who is this Timothy Taylor figure
showing up in Bledsoe's life?
He's a mysterious rocket scientist
who's done mission control for NASA since the 80s.
That part is not really disputed
and it's well-documented in his autobiography,
Launch Fever.
At one point, Tim Taylor even had a small YouTube account
with videos showing his deep levels of access
to NASA facilities.
He's also taken people like Bledsoe
through Kennedy Space Center.
Religious studies professor Diana Pasolka,
along with others, have said that he's worked directly
with Elon Musk.
But where it gets interesting is that he's also popping up
in the lives of numerous UFO experiencers,
claiming that he's a time traveler and works for an angel.
Basically, he exists at the intersection
between rigorous real-world aerospace work
and totally insane UFO lore.
And that's why he's still amazing.
He's one of American Alchemy's most requested guests.
Some of the things that Tim Taylor told Chris
would wholesale overhaul our understanding of reality,
if at all true.
Really smart guy, like genius level, and, uh.
Really?
Yeah.
I enjoyed his company.
We did a lot of stuff together.
We traveled together.
Um, we were able to recover some metal together.
Wow.
Yeah.
I didn't know that.
I was in Ohio.
In Ohio?
Yeah.
Where in Ohio?
In a little town called Zanes, well.
Zanesville.
Zanesville, yeah.
Zanesville, Ohio.
Yeah.
Do you know who's from Zanesville, Ohio?
Yeah, I do.
T-town's in Brown, right?
What?
He took you to Zanesville, Ohio,
where you recovered a little piece of metal?
Yeah.
A pretty good piece, about that big.
You're sure you went to Zanesville?
Yeah.
In fact, I went in a machine shop, he and I,
and had a piece sawed off the metal,
which he took with them.
And we gave the other piece back to the person that had it.
And I knew the person,
and he wouldn't give it to anyone in the world,
but he called me and he drives up in his yard
and there's this red piece of glowing,
he sees this thing over his house
and it goes away when he drives up,
but there was a piece of red glowing metal in the yard.
He lets it cool, picks it up and puts it in a shoe box
and there it stays for 15 years.
No way.
And when he found out about me and read the story,
he calls me and says,
I got something I want you to see.
And so I called Taylor and he and I flew up there.
This is either engineered to make me excited
or this is the most remarkable story ever.
I almost lost it during this part of the interview.
Zanesville, Ohio, is where Thomas Townsend Brown
was born.
To me, Townsend Brown is the most interesting
historical figure in the 20th century
that no one knows about.
I've independently uncovered an absurd amount of information
that leads me to believe that Townsend Brown
essentially discovered anti-gravity in the 1950s.
He was funded by the same physics patrons
at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
that sent science down the wrong path
with quantum gravity in 1957.
He was also backed by the highest levels
of CIA and aerospace.
There are even videos of Townsend Brown
at the University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
celebrating because his experiments presumably worked.
Here he is with a bottle of champagne.
And we know due to real declassified documents
written by the head of Australia's nuclear program,
Harry Turner, and often cited by UFO whistleblower,
David Grush, that University of North Carolina Chapel Hill
was waist deep in anti-gravity research.
We also have a deathbed confession
of French aerospace representative, Jacques Corneillon,
saying that Townsend Brown's experiments worked in Paris,
in the Montgolfier facility in 1956.
The tests were very, very, very tricky.
It was sensitive to so many things in vacuum.
Finally it worked, so that was a positive result.
And that's just the tip of the spear.
We also have Carl Nell, who helped set up army
the Futures Command, which led all tech modernization efforts
for the army, implying that Townsend Brown
made breakthroughs in the world of gravity.
Jesse's done a number of podcasts
looking into Townsend Brown
and some other very interesting, like, heretical technologies.
So I'd invite people, an unsolicited plug,
to check out some of Jesse's podcasts.
Not to mention NASA's top scientist in electrostatics,
Charles Buehler, literally leaving NASA
to start a propellant plant.
It's a thoughtless, gravity-based propulsion system
that he says is a derivative of Townsend Brown's work.
The term asymmetric electrical pressure
is similar to Thomas Townsend Brown's research
into asymmetrical capacitors.
Those older papers and that older subject matter
is probably valid for most of the point.
I could go on, but I'll spare you.
The fact that Chris Bledsoe was taken to Zanesville, Ohio,
an otherwise completely unremarkable little Ohio town,
is a very unlikely coincidence.
And the fact that the goal there
was to retrieve an exotic piece of metal
seems even more unlikely,
especially given that Tim Taylor
was escorting Bledsoe there.
As you're about to hear in this conversation,
there are tons of other bizarre connections
between NASA mission controller Tim Taylor
and mid-century anti-gravity inventor Townsend Brown.
This episode is sponsored by Superpower.
On this show, we spend all of our time trying
to understand reality,
but most of us are simply guessing
when it comes to our own health.
With conventional healthcare,
you're firing totally blindly.
You go to the doctor, you get a few basic labs,
and you're told everything looks normal.
But that thing that doesn't feel great,
the chronic headaches, the stomach pain, the back pain,
you don't ever really get insight on any of it.
You don't get the proper data you need.
You get no actionable insights and no real plan.
That's why Superpower caught my attention.
Superpower gives you a deep look
at what's actually happening inside your body.
It's a single blood draw, either at home or a nearby lab,
and they measure over 100 biomarkers,
way more than a standard physical.
You get real data on things like hormones, metabolism,
heart health, vitamin and mineral levels,
even environmental toxins, toxins that can accumulate
and cause very bad things to happen in your body.
What I like is that Superpower doesn't stop at the numbers.
They turn those results
into a clear, personalized action plan,
what to focus on, and what not to focus on.
With nutrition, what supplements actually make sense for you,
lifestyle adjustments.
You can even get your true biological age
and can track how that changes over time.
Instead of guessing when it comes to your health,
you finally have a map,
your full health blueprint activated with Superpower.
Not only did Superpower reduce their price to just $199,
but for a limited time,
our listeners get an additional $20 off with code ALCHEMY.
Again, that's Superpower.
Head to Superpower.com and use code ALCHEMY at checkout
for $20 off your membership.
After you sign up, they'll ask you how you heard about them.
Please make sure to mention this podcast to support the show.
And so if there's a connection between this NASA mission controller
who's obsessed with UFOs and this mid-century anti-gravity inventor,
and then you're literally going to Zanesville, Ohio to collect UFO material,
which is where it's a, that's a random place.
And that's where Townsend Brown was born in 1905.
And there's their newspaper, you know,
clippings of him creating, you know,
wireless telegram basically at the age of 12 or something.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
True story.
That's so crazy.
And I can show you the metal.
I'll give you a picture of it.
Can't please?
Yeah.
Can I feel the metal?
Well, I don't own it.
You don't own it.
Okay. Yeah. Tim has it.
I would love, I would love to see the picture.
Yeah.
And learn anything else about the Zanesville trip.
That's just fascinating.
Tim got it originally.
And then Dr. Putoff got another piece of it.
Putoff got another piece.
So I took Tom DeLonge and Lou Elizondo to Zanesville
or to Pennsylvania or Ohio, I mean.
You took them to Ohio, to Zanesville?
I took them to the same guy's house
and got them a piece of it as well.
Were Tom DeLonge and Lou aware of Townsend Brown?
I didn't discuss it with them.
You didn't discuss that with them?
No.
So do you-
But that's where some of their metal came from.
Plus some that I had, I had three pieces of it.
Do you think Putoff knows about Townsend Brown?
Yeah.
He does?
Yeah, I'm sure.
Yeah, he told me he met him.
Yeah.
But that he never, you know,
he didn't know how far he got, you know, sort of thing.
Right, right.
But how, you know, how it can be a little cheeky,
but interesting.
Yeah.
For the audience.
I mean, I'm sure they know this,
but I'm obsessed with this mid-century anti-gravity inventor,
Thomas Townsend Brown, who I am very convinced
made real updates in the world of gravity.
He was a very nuts and bolts, you know, inventor.
And he worked at the highest levels of military government
with every kind of aerospace company you could guess.
I mean, there's an FBI document on him
saying he was the foremost radar expert in the Navy.
And he was in charge of the Philadelphia experiment,
actually, which has all this lore about it.
And who knows whether the, you know,
prima facie story of that is true.
But he was at, you know, Martin Vega,
the year that Skunk Works formed.
Right.
He, you know, knew Curtis LeMay,
knew Bill Lear, the inventor of the Learjet.
Right.
He was being funded by the guys
who were sending physics down the wrong path
while he was doing his, I think,
more vital kind of anti-gravity experiments.
But the kind of subplot of his life
is that gravity and time
are very interrelated in general relativity.
And what I found so fascinating is
I made this whole documentary on Thomas Townsend Brown.
And at the end of the documentary,
I make this connection that Tim Taylor told your son,
Ryan Bledsoe, that he was part of a secret time travel group
in Nassau, in the Bahamas,
and that Thomas Townsend Brown was the president.
And even then, maybe I would have dismissed it out of hand,
but I had become this amateur historian of Townsend Brown,
and he would always go to Nassau, in the Bahamas.
And then if you read Tim Taylor's biography,
Launch Fever, he's in Nassau a lot.
So that does kind of place them both in, you know,
in Nassau at some times.
It's called the Nassau Group.
The Nassau Group.
Yeah.
So he took you to, was the piece of metal,
this UFO metal in Zanesville related
to Townsend Brown at all, or?
Well, there was a lot of conversation about that.
And the amount of activity around that place,
he said, was all part of the land,
because where this metal was found,
it was near the Indian Serpent Mound.
Right.
So they know that there's a lot of activity.
And he told me stories about Townsend Brown.
What did he say about Townsend Brown?
Well, you know, his daughter was doing a book,
and Tim was helping her with that book.
Tim was helping her with that book?
Yeah, he helped write that book, her book.
I didn't know that.
I do know, I found an Amazon review from his daughter
about Tim Taylor's book, Launch Fever.
And this was before anybody knew about, you know,
Tim Taylor, because he hadn't even been written about,
you know, pseudonymously in American Cosmic
by Dana Pasulka.
This is in the early 2010s.
Yeah.
So he was helping Linda Brown write her book.
Write her book, yeah.
I didn't know that.
That's amazing.
And what did he say about Townsend Brown?
Yeah.
What did he say about Townsend Brown himself?
He told me he'd heard stories of these little things
coming and landing in his yard and getting out
and giving him information.
That's real.
Well, at least according to his daughter,
his daughter did a sort of AMA on, you know,
Ask Me Anything on Reddit.
She talked about beings coming down and then entering,
I think it was like, she was in the,
they were in the kitchen with her dad and her,
and they were these sort of pale skinned, you know,
looked alien, like looked from a, you know,
like they were from another planet
or existed in another environment.
And they talked all night.
And then, you know, they wake up the next morning,
she thinks it's a dream.
And then two nights later, they're at dinner
and she brings up the dream and Thomas Townsend Brown goes,
that wasn't a dream or something like that.
Right, exactly.
Wow.
Did he ever insinuate on what the Nassau group,
this time travel group in the Bahamas, right?
Thomas was doing?
He didn't.
He just told me at one point that he thought
I may have to go hide out there a while.
Really?
That was when it really first happened way back.
Because it was a dangerous place.
The whole world was different in 2008.
It was the highest secured thing in the world.
The UFO was more classified higher than the nuclear bomb.
But you would have to hang out in Nassau.
Well, they mentioned that I may have to go there
for protection.
Interesting.
Yeah.
So what's there?
I don't know.
I just, that was all he told me.
You know, he writes in Launch Fever, his biography,
about flying these cargo jets back and forth
between Florida and Nassau.
And I think the guy he was flying with was like selling drugs
and he didn't even know about it.
Like it was like, he was just kind of being like
along for the ride or whatever.
But then he says some really trippy things around.
He goes, time moved differently in Nassau.
But he's saying it like it's like island time, you know?
So it's like, and then you're like, is that coded?
Cause he's telling you, you know,
and Diana Pasolka about the adjustment bureau
and like, you know, timeline hopping.
And then he's saying time moves different
in this Nassau group, in Nassau.
But then he's also telling your son and you,
that he's in a secret time travel group
with Townsend Brown in Nassau.
So I'm like, is he writing in code there?
Probably, yeah.
Those guys are all about, yeah, they're so super secretive.
They can, they'll tell you things and code like that.
It's up to you to get it or not, but yeah.
I want to meet the Nassau group.
How do we do that?
I have no idea.
I don't know how I would find them or why.
Well, it's just a lot.
But I just have no idea where I was
when I was in ,
I was just, that was something told to me years ago
and Ryan heard it and it never left me.
But as far as where and how and who, I don't know.
We never got involved.
Yeah, cause , it's so like,
the world's so interesting.
Cause he also, I believe he told you
and I think Diana Pasolka that, you know,
he said, read the adjustment team
or watch the adjustment bureau.
Yeah. Yeah.
Which is this, the original talk episode was, you know,
was a philip k dick book right and then this movie with matt damon and it's all about adjusting
little variables to change timelines right and he viewed his role in reality as doing that right
and so do you think he actually viewed his role as as doing that as part of this sort of timeline
adjustment you mean tim tim taylor yeah he's told me he was the one who told me to read to watch the
movie he said that movie was created for a reason watch it it's a lot like that and um then he said
and in that movie you'll find a character named the hammer and he said and i work for the hammer
and the hammer works for god i'm like you gotta tell me more than that and that's all he would
tell me he said i work for the hammer and the hammer works for god and you what do you think
the hammer is well in the movie he's in like an
arcane
angel he's the guy that the lesser beings couldn't couldn't stop what was happening
because of love you know if you watch the movie that's so fascinating so they send the hammer down
to to take care of it and of course i won't spoil the movie but yeah it ends up well
yeah but yeah well i mean do you do you think
that he's in touch with a celestial being with an angel he insinuated that and um i can probably
believe that yeah something yeah whether it's an angel or what i don't know so what would the
because he seems to show up in a lot of you know super experiencers lives so there are people who've
had experiences here and there and then there are people like you who have repeated experiences and
a lot of interactions with this other world right
and i found it very interesting that he showed up in charles hall's life and then he shows up in
your life um i think he knew whitley streber as well um you say timothy taylor yeah oh he's a good
friend of ours oh so you know you know timothy taylor he came here because he found out about
charles and that was when his daughter the one who had the the baby was like what was she doing
maybe in fifth grade when they came the first time yeah we why do you think he was he became
interested in your story my wife can answer all the questions because he he realized that as far
as he was concerned that charles was the the real article was legitimate and as i say it's really
concerned me because i've tried to email other people because he
brought other people to meet us and a visit with us they they one of the guys cooked right here in
my kitchen and so i tried to contact those people because i had in uh emails for them and i never
got a response about what happened to him so what do you what do you think it is with him do you
think there's some mandate from the hammer from this angel or something to interact with experiencers
if he's been
truthful about that i would say that's probably correct there's some kind of mandate guiding him
so he's definitely connected i mean big time do you think he was being truthful or yeah well you
you know sometimes you wonder if it's all uh smoke and mirrors designed to throw you off course you
know but i listened to everything i worked with him for three or four years before diana met him
i introduced diana to tim we were working on crazy stuff
like stem cell research and i have no idea what that is and
what proteins are and anything medical right i'm a carpenter and yet i'm reading papers at night
that they would send me and my job was to draw whatever came out of me whatever i saw and so
usually every week i'm sending in some sort of diagram of cells and all kinds of things whoa yeah
As you know, on American Alchemy, we cover a lot of technology that goes beyond human limits.
This is about technology that helps the body catch up and feel good.
I'm talking about the iRestore LED face mask, a red light therapy system that uses clinical grade wavelengths to boost skin cell energy production.
The same exact principle used in the top recovery clinics and bio-optimization labs in the world.
I've been using it most nights, 10 minutes while I'm reading, prepping for a show, or decompressing.
It's completely hands-free, comfortable, and engineered to deliver consistent light intensity across the face.
Not that uneven scatter most cheaper masks use.
It feels like your face is taking a warm bath.
What it's doing is called photobiomodulation, stimulating mitochondria to repair tissue, reduce inflammation, and improve circulation.
You actually feel the calm and rejuvenation after a session.
I've tested a few.
This one really stands out for the build quality.
It feels like it was built in a high-precision lab, and it's not just a cheap beauty gadget.
So if you're into real evidence-based recovery tech, this belongs in your setup.
Head to iRestore.com and use code JESSE25 for an exclusive discount.
Again, iRestore.com, code JESSE25.
Red light therapy has really been a game-changer for me, so I hope you love it.
So it's almost like you were part of a sequel.
It's almost like you were part of a secret science program where you were given material to look at.
You didn't even have context on the material, but you were getting downloads about it.
And do you think any of that made it into his, you know, he had a lot of biomedical patents.
He had a company called Vivex Biotechnologies, which he sold for $88 million.
That's who I was working with.
That's who you were working with.
That company.
Wow.
Yeah.
They were creating what's called a biograph, which was based on...
Metal.
The metal that they've recovered and infusing it into this, well, the particular, and I have video of the operation of a young lady,
the first operation in the United States, was a Spanish lady that had bone cancer in her thigh,
and they removed like two inches of the bone, and they wrapped it with this biograph, injected stem cells into it,
and in like 60 days, her bone had regrown, the pain was gone, she could walk again.
Whoa.
Yeah.
Yeah, no, I mean, that is a operational, functional, you know, company that does real things in the biomedical world.
And what makes it fascinating is that maybe the backdrop of that company is recovered UFO material.
Exactly.
And somebody like you intuitively downloading the functionality.
I don't know how much good I did, right?
But I...
It was to come from a carpenter being ridiculed by the whole community to secretly drawing diagrams for NASA was, you know, it was a pretty cool thing.
Well, you know, you have all these rumors of like Philip J. Corso and, you know, him being involved in, you know,
I think the Army's, you know, foreign technology desk and transferring, you know, crash materials from Roswell, for example, to Bell Labs,
so they could...
You know, help build, you know, semiconductors, things like that.
Right.
But what you don't hear of is people download, people like yourself who are intuitively kind of tapped in downloading...
...aspects of the functionality of some of these technologies.
That's really interesting.
Well, that...
I'm learning.
I'm learning over the last night.
It's been 19 years I've been doing this, right?
A long time.
And in that time, I've learned a lot and I keep learning every day.
But I...
There is a great correlation with the phenomenon guiding us and creating things in our path.
And if you're smart enough and you pay attention to that, all kinds of things come.
It's like being Sherlock Holmes.
I'm like, oh, boy, what's next?
You know, so that's kind of the way I've modeled my life is letting it guide my path rather than me try to drive the bus.
I let...
Let...
I call it the lady, right?
Or that, the phenomenon.
Yeah.
Yeah, the...
It's like the way is not the way.
Like, you have to...
You have to...
Or I think there's a concept called Wu Wei, which is effortless effort.
And there's sort of sitting back, being receptive, listening to the signs, and then just kind of, you know, following the path.
Right.
And that's an art.
You know, it's easy to get into this mode of being attached and trying to over-engineer outcomes.
Exactly.
For example, in the music world, I happened to...
I wrote about something that happened.
And I was given a message that there...
That the divine world encodes messages within the music that we listen to, and we just don't know it, right?
So it's being channeled by these musicians.
And that led me on...
I'll tell you how manifestation works.
It's because...
When I was given that information, I was given five or six songs.
Six.
Five right away and one at another point.
And when I read the lyrics on it, it was like, oh, my God, this is crazy.
This is crazy.
I couldn't believe it.
You hear these songs, but you never read the words.
Well, that day in 2012, I said, Lord, I wish I could tell Sammy Hagar from Van Halen or Robert Plant.
Or Jimmy Page or Neil Young.
These are the guys...
Or Metallica, right?
These are the guys that I just said the simple little prayer.
You know, right off the top of my head, Lord, I wish I could tell them.
Wow, this is what I was thinking.
Last year, on my birthday, I get a phone call.
And it's Sammy's wife, Kari.
And we become friends.
And then it turned into Kurt Hammett with Metallica.
And then I get a text from my friend.
He said, hey, Chris, I'm in the pub in England.
And sitting beside me is Robert Plant.
And he's reading your book.
No way.
That's crazy.
And he sent you a happy birthday.
And the same two days later, I get a call from Fred Durst, Limp Bizkit.
Oh, yeah.
Well, he's super into UFOs.
I love Fred.
I think he has a UFO podcast.
Yeah.
I've been on his podcast.
Cool.
So, anyhow, it just all poured out.
And it manifested.
I didn't do it.
I didn't seek these people out.
They called me.
And now that's Sammy told me that the song Love Walks In,
he don't even know where the words came from.
It just came out of him.
And this song is like, you have to read the lyrics on it.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well, I didn't even.
I mean, it's crazy how much music is influenced by this stuff.
Like, I think Paul McCartney.
One of the Beatles had a dream about a flaming pie.
Right.
And that was how the Beatles name came about somehow.
I didn't know.
It was going to be spelled differently.
Wow.
Beatles.
And then it moved into B-A-T-L-E-S after this flaming pie came down in this dream or something.
That is.
And so, yeah, you have a lot of these sort of stories.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Do you think that, you know, because we often think of like, you know, the aerospace world.
That's interested in a lot of what you're doing is very kind of nuts and bolts focused.
Not.
Right.
They don't care about, you know, downloads or experiences or whatever.
Do you feel like they really do?
They are really interested in the phenomenon and they are learning from it as much as they are just, you know, writing equations on chalkboards.
A million percent.
In fact, in the last year I've seen or two years, I've seen.
A huge increase in the scientists, mainstream scientists that, you know, forever like Diana.
She was the first Ph.D. that would even talk about this, right?
And back then, if you even said this out loud, people would laugh and walk away.
Nobody would talk.
But now, there's over 200 mainstream scientists right now.
That was the word I was told by Dr. Estevez, Anna Brady Estevez.
Oh, yeah.
She's been.
She's been on the podcast.
We're still coming out with something cool.
Yeah.
But she.
American deep tech.
She's told me that there's at least 200 scientists that want to start working on this thing.
It's fascinating.
Yeah, it's fascinating.
And it almost feels like at times the scientists are being coordinated on a higher level.
Yeah.
And this gets into like the three body problem or, you know, science fiction novels like that where, you know,
the way that.
That the phenomena speaks to us is through scientific discoveries, innovation, through serendipitous meetings between scientists.
Yeah.
And I'm sure it's the same thing with art and other creation.
Big time and to the creativity world, artists of all kinds.
In other words, I don't mean to interrupt, but if I had to say of all the people that call me that the majority of these experiencers, a good majority of them will be artists.
That paint that make music that act are different type of people and created people.
And for some reason, they're the ones that have a lot of this experience and have been for years.
Makes sense that they'd be tapped in.
I think it's more interesting in a sense that somebody like, you know, I've spoken to how put off about this and he goes, I always follow the synchronicities and when they stop, I know I'm on the wrong path or whatever.
And it's like, this guy is a very.
Serious scientist who's popping up, not only in areas of quote unquote, UFO science, but in, you know, prosaically very interesting science.
Right.
So pretty serious guy.
Yeah.
And we were talking outside.
It sounds like you're in touch with some Lockheed guys too.
Yeah.
What's what's the deal there?
Well, I have friends everywhere.
This is no shortage of people from NASA.
Uh, from Lockheed, from three, um, from, uh, from all over these scientists, but my, uh, I haven't have a friend that is a material scientist that works with this material and, um, he kind of stays pretty close to me, following me about, and we, we travel together and we study together and doing a lot of things right now.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Who's that?
I can't do this.
Does he, uh, work at a, a big aerospace corporation or?
He, uh, well, he, yeah, you'll see him one day at, uh, he lives in Silicon Valley, but you'll see him one day.
He'll be in a skiff somewhere under an airport or he'll be in, uh, at NASA or he'll be somewhere in amongst all that.
Um, yeah.
Fascinating.
Yeah.
It's so interesting.
He's educated me a lot on this metal and how it acts and, and how it acts differently in zero gravity than it does on, on ground level.
How does the metal act differently in zero gravity?
It's, um, it, it has a way of, um, well, just, let's just say that the words I heard, this metal is much, acts much like an animal and that it is always seeking.
For energy and seeking to connect and how I got this pen was being off planet and being tested by that metal, knowing that it bonded to me.
So that's why this phenomenon is always around is it is trying to reconnect all the time.
And because you went up on a craft, you're somehow connected with the metal.
Yeah.
How do you think you're connected with it?
Into the DNA is all I know.
It's a frequency.
I think our DNA.
It's transmitted in a frequency, which I've seen the papers on it and, uh, and, uh, a radar type frequency.
So it's pinging and it's receiving, sending and receiving.
And, um, so it's always, it's always, once it connects with you on that level, and I'm being very careful not to say a whole lot here, but I get a phone call if I say too much.
Right.
So, yeah.
Well, they're clearly trying to, cause they know you have a public presence.
They are going to get asked about this stuff, so they want to get it out somewhat would be my guess, you know, there's a, you know, there's a scientist named Constantine mile.
He's in the black forest in Germany, and he, uh, talks about, uh, scalar physics and its relationship with DNA specifically like DNA resonance with these exotic electromagnetic waves that exist in the scalar field.
Um, which if you think about it.
If we are getting any sort of messages via our DNA, a transverse Hertzian, a classic electromagnetic wave doesn't really make sense because it decays one at one over R squared.
So if you're in a Faraday chamber, you're, you know, kind of in some remote place or whatever, the decay function on a normal electromagnetic wave would be too stark, uh, for you to really receive a lot of information on going.
Right.
Probably.
If you're in a, if you're a lab or a lab or a laboratory and you're seeing these waves that travel at one over R.
Which a lot of these kind of deeper aerospace scientists believe possibly exist.
Right.
Um, maybe your body would be able to download and encode a lot more information and they say they think that the son is a scalar wave generator.
So maybe the sun is constantly spurring evolution.
Tim Taylor talks about in Diana's book American cosmic that he's his protocols are around, you know, you know, being able to, you know, are speaking, um, um, uh, you know, you're able to hear, you know, things where you don't hear, you know, three people in a lab talking and, and, and, and you're able to hear several different things, which is not necessarily the same thing.
cosmic that he's his protocols are around you know you know being in the sunlight looking at
the sun well that's it and and um in fact um i've read the paper on it 15 years ago 13 years ago
and the thought is that the sun the way it shines at an angle on the earth it creates the green
color spectrum which is the center of the color spectrum right and in that our um the sun is is
affecting what's called adt which is the hemoglobin in your blood and the chlorophyll
implant so it when it hits that it starts this energy and it starts creating life
and so the sun is telling everything how to be a pear how to be a grass how to be a tree how to be
me or you so all the
information of life is coming from that green light from what they're saying it's just constantly
sending all information all encoding to every living thing birds that's where it comes from
yeah it's really amazing i mean there's there's this idea of the anthropic principle which is
why is earth you know this perfect kind of homeostatic like just place that that fosters
life
and there you know a couple of different explanations for it one is like we've tried
a million different iterations this is the goldilocks so and we just got really lucky
or whatever to to live in the the the one where it's perfect and then there's another one which
is this has been sort of created or simulated you know for for life and if you think about
the earth's magnetosphere the way it blocks cosmic radiation but allows just enough cosmic
radiation to allow for the perfect amount of natural selection to allow for you know
real real evolution um but then the magnetosphere of the earth itself like literally the schumann
resonance fosters human and animal morphology right and and this sort of perfect way if you put
a frog embryo in a faraday chamber where that's blocked it doesn't grow normally
so it's this like the these perfect sort of circumstances so one thing we figured out
this past year i was on um john alexander called me two or three times chris nobody got it and i was like
yeah i was on the um this beyond skinwalker show with brandon fugal right so we were at the
monroe institute and they took me in the basement of the lab and put me in a faraday cage and it's
uh it's silent it's walls like the stick with uh you know i'm in i'm in the basement of the lab
in a build in a basically a coffin is what it looked like with ceilings are copper and the
walls are copper so no electromagnetic
can get in there and so they had all these cameras outside pointing up at the sky
and i'm in this thing and uh they have uh dr thompson from from new york uh neuros neuro phd
and neuroscience was monitoring me and uh he said if you if you sense a ufo over the complex just
point to the ceiling every time i pointed they were filming something above the the building
and that from that point on um john and a whole lot of other scientists says this proves this
consciousness it's not electromagnetic it's consciousness so it's instantaneous it's like
thoughts which is what's creating everything wow yeah yeah well if you think of you know we have
phonons which are sort of you know quantum vibration packets and then you
photons which are quantum light packets maybe at some point we'll figure out quantum thought
packets or something that's it it's all thought it's just it's just how it works with me you know
i don't have to go out and speak to get this thing to come i just think about it who knows our
thoughts completely and in advance of what you're going to think you can't fool it wow at all there's
no way wow
this episode is sponsored by true classic this is one of my favorite shirts it kind of works for
every occasion i honestly didn't think i cared about t-shirts until i realized how many of them
i don't wear they end up just accumulating in your closet most of them look fine on a hanger
then you put them on and something's off they're too boxy they're too stiff they're too long
or they just kind of hang weird that's the problem true classic set out to fix
they focus on the fit first which in my opinion is the most important thing about a t-shirt
when it comes to a shirt shirts that sit right on your shoulders and chest relax where they should
and don't feel like you're wearing cardboard the material is also extremely soft breathable and
flexible you put one on and you don't think about it again which is kind of the goal i've been wearing
their shirts for a while now and i always reach for them when i know i just want a standard quality
shirt when i don't want to think about what i'm wearing but i know i'll be dressed appropriately
for any occasion you don't like it when you're wearing a t-shirt and you don't like it when you're
wearing a t-shirt you look overly formal you don't look disheveled you look just right they
started with men's basics but now they make clothes for women and kids too same focus on
comfort and fit and they keep the prices extremely reasonable instead of charging you for a logo and
a story this company isn't about trends or fashion cycles it's about having a consistent standard of
quality and a few pieces you can always go to that won't let you down so if you want to get
some super high quality shirts go to trueclassic.com
slash jesse to refresh your wardrobe for 2026 you can also find them at amazon target costco
and sam's club thank you to true classic for sponsoring today's episode i want to go where
other people haven't gone in interviews with you right do you feel like you know when you read like
uh this is going to sound like a crazy question but like when you read the book of acts and you
know learn about jesus do you feel like
he is a state of being that others can get to through kind of you know really spiritual profound
kind of experiences what diana pasulka calls in her book hierophanies revelations and again this
is not to make him out to be this exclusive untouchable you know being or state but like
maybe maybe some people can reach a state and do you feel like maybe you're you're in that sort of
consciousness and that allows you to to have 100 effect on people yeah 100 and um you know the way
i was born and raised a baptist and and married a pentecostal holiness girl and and you know it
was very deep into the church and loved it and my wife still goes she was at church yesterday
and um for the day before sunday but the way you know when jesus came he
he wasn't a christian he was just saying the kingdom of heaven is within you you you you can
talk to god yourself and you don't need to pay anybody to have that and i don't think they liked
him saying that a whole lot and his life was cut short because of that well that's one of my
favorite lines it's in an apocryphal you know the gospel of thomas but it's you know if you look to
the sea the fish will precede you if you look to the sky the birds will precede you the kingdom of
heaven is inside of you and you know it's a very important line and it's a very important line and
you know it's a very important line and it's a very important line and it's a very important line
inside of you exactly and all around you and um you know and then you'll have
hardcore biblical scholars say oh that was written 150 years later and it doesn't matter that's the
words jesus used the kingdom of heaven is within you that spark that divine spark and
and you can yeah do you how do you how do you because like i feel like my
on world view and ontology in some ways matches a lot of what you're saying
of yours and what you say and then i think there are a lot of people out there who are like
who is this guy saying that he sees orbs and you know that's at 747 or a satellite or whatever
what do you say to those people um you know i expect that i've learned until you see it
experience that um you're just uninformed you know it's real it's 100 real and i have
shared it with you and i've shared it with you and i've shared it with you and i've shared it with you
the groups as large as a thousand at one time with a pa and as the most liberal ufo group you know
i've ever been to was contact in the desert this past summer right and here i am being drugged by
the hand all day you need to be in this room at this time this room at that time hadn't eaten all
day hadn't been to the bathroom and it's like seven o'clock at night and i'm finally you know
and i deal with rheumatoids so my energy levels
are low my wife comes in or the uh my assistant comes and he says oh you got a sky watch at
at at uh nine o'clock it was eight then i'm like oh my god i forgot all about that
huge pressure it's it's cloudy it's raining in palm springs it never rains in palm springs right
it's sprinkling and they said there's a big group sitting outside waiting on you
so i like
i'm like i took my told my wife i said take me somewhere to where nobody can see me because if
they see me there was always 50 people in line right so she took me over to a little seating
area where it was dark and i lay back i looked up at the sky and i said lord i need help i'm stressed
tonight it's raining there's a thousand people out there wanting to see something
and suddenly when i said that my wife sat beside me i heard this
telepathic voice say don't worry about the rain it'll just get more interesting
and then i saw these three orange orbs come down under the clouds and this digital digit
it said 945 just flashed right up i said okay there'll be three orange orbs at 945
so i got up i walked over to the center of a thousand people they're in a big circle and i'm
in a 20-foot circle that they take me to a dry place and i'm just walking over to a thousand
people and they're in a big circle and i'm in a 20-foot circle and i'm walking over to a thousand
people and they're in a big circle and i'm in a 20-foot circle
there's a gr Fennell it's especially inside the Judd Fortin space so i'm in a big circle if you're
looking around the ground you'll notice how there's a splatoon coming and some asking
kept that where I could walk around in it with a microphone.
And so I told the whole group an hour in advance,
I said at 9.45, there'll be three orange orbs
that appear underneath the clouds.
And exactly at 9.45, it happened.
Whoa, do you have video of that?
Yeah. Wow.
And you can hear me on the microphone.
It's all recorded, predicting it an hour in advance.
But I didn't predict it, I saw it, it shared it with me.
Mm, wow.
That's so fascinating.
It's like the Fatima prophecy,
but compressed and at a UFO conference.
But you know what I did?
What? I'm at a UFO conference
and they're, you know, some of them's got tinfoil hats on
and they have all these Galactic Federation,
well, I, yeah, it doesn't compute with me, right?
So I basically held a little church
at the most liberal thing, not church,
but I said, look, we're just gonna say a little prayer here.
This is how it works.
Listen to me.
There is no summoning.
All this thing you hear about summoning these things,
that's, if they're having negative experiences,
whoever's doing this, well, that's why.
Because you're open to anything coming.
But I always use a little prayer.
And so I just told them, I said,
I believe that the Holy Spirit is this beautiful lady
that gave me this information and I'm just gonna ask her,
Mm-hmm.
I'm gonna ask her right now
to share her presence with us.
And that's the only thing I said.
What do you think of,
cause it seems like you're coming at this
from a very spiritual perspective.
There are rumors that the Legacy UFO Program itself
uses protocols to attract UFOs to come in,
sometimes use directed energy weapons against them,
get them to land psionically
through what they call psionic assets.
So that would be finding somebody maybe similar,
similarly tapped in as you are,
but who's sort of not maybe come about it
in the more kind of earnest spiritual way
through life experience that you did.
Maybe they just have some ability
or maybe they've been given a protocol or something.
What are psionic assets?
When we look at collecting data,
one of the areas that we look to collect data
is through a psionic asset,
which is an individual who's trained in remote viewing,
psychic abilities, telekinesis,
that type of thing,
which is basically through a number of different protocols
can transition into a place
where they are highly sensitive to their environment
from the point of view of consciousness,
through a consciousness field.
How do you feel about that?
Attracting crafts to come down,
trying to derive material from these crafts
or get downloads from them?
uh but for like defense you know kind of military industrial complex purposes well i've been uh you
know i work in and around a lot of those people and i've had a lot of proposals that uh and you
wouldn't believe um even proposals if i could get it to come down could they shoot at it i'm like
absolutely not yeah that's not going to happen with me you want to study it what i what i see
is um is wanting to communicate with us um you hear about all that but i've not seen any of it
i haven't seen the results so there's a lot of talk out there but not a lot of data to show
right where i show the data i take a thousand people out or 500 out and we get things that
appear to have wings orange glowing beings as many as 20 at the time fly 25 feet over our head
appear out of thin air poop come right over us glowing and um so it's very spiritual and sacred
to me and i would never um but as far as you know i heard some of the things on asia disclosure and
they were talking about negative parts of it um orbs being negative um i've never experienced that
ever in my whole 19 years of doing it in fact you talked about the book of acts when um
saul was on the road to damascus what was it that appeared and blinded him
what was it it was an orb whoa flashed him said it flashed around him blinded him
it was a ball of light same thing and so you know it's all in your thought process if you grounded
with that humbleness and earnesty and you love then you're going to get that but if you put
something out i mean if we want aliens right
we create this in our brain if we want aliens with red guns if you get enough of the population
to think on that that's probably what will manifest what do you think the orbs are it's
this sort of perennial question because i think a lot of people have these experiences i think a lot
you know they they'll meditate they'll be deep in prayer and they'll see something come i i have an
experience like that where i was doing holotropic breath work with a friend in silver lake california
of all places like the last place where i was doing holotropic breath work with a friend in
silver lake california and we saw two metallic orbs show up and it doesn't feel coincidental that
like you know for him i think it was his first time doing holotropic breath work and right you
know you're supposed that's supposed to get you into a state where your brain i think endogenously
releases dmt and you're right you're in this kind of heightened spiritual state um what do i think
it is what do you think they are well um i'm very careful to try not to
label because it's all speculation you know you ask the question what do you think well i'm guessing
right all of us are sure and nobody's experienced that i don't think any more than i have i see it
just about every day of my life and it comes in my house orbs appearing in my room over my chairs
and flying through the house and stuff so you think you experience it more than anybody in the
world i haven't seen anybody with the data i have and show me the data and then we you know what i'm
seeing but people are seeing it now and i predicted that in my book you'll read where i
wrote about a certain incident that was going to happen in the future which was when iran and israel
began to exchange missiles at one another at that point is when these balls of light these orbs were
going to start appearing and revealing themselves to the world i wrote about that and that was
something i've talked about for 10 12 years and then look last november
these drones supposedly drones that show up those aren't drones
they're orbs coming out of the sea appearing and they're saying stop they de-escalated and they
kind of settled they started putting f-35s in poland all of a sudden now there's orbs all over
europe so what do you think the orbs are based on uh the patterns that i've seen i'm saying i'm
guessing right
but um 19 years of uh research and prayer simple prayer that mindset don't have to say it verbally
just think it um lends me to believe it's something uh connected to our thoughts very
caring loving um and our beings i can share a video with you of an orb with a lady standing
beside me and another lady i go
on each side this one has cancer stage four kidney cancer jesus and she's missing one kidney already
year and a half later it metastasizes in her other kidney she calls me so she's worried about
her the chemo is not working so she had a very um poor chance of survival so she calls me and
comes to my house this was in 2015 i guess and uh 2013 maybe
michigan what fringe test she and she brings her girlfriends like five of them so all of
those myself a wife and some of my children and three native americans they're outside there
they just happen to show up at the same time friends of mine and so i got them to kind of do a
song that they do for healing for her all of a sudden in the video you'll see an orb appear
and it comes zooming right up to me and all of a sudden the person that she's talking about is know
she's been in this area for at least a few years um she's kind of seenский i'm sure people know her
she's putting her immune system on a lot of things in her body a lot of things they're maybe doing she's
in a very Canyon range and she's got amazingolved challenges in terms of extinguishing some of those
it flashes and out of that comes a tall glowing figure about six to seven feet tall and then it
just kind of moves over out of the camera right in front of this lady and then she goes to get
her scan on monday and has no more cancer what yeah and i have it on video so i would love to
see that video i'll share it in a little bit with you that would be amazing that's amazing so 19
years i have more data about this and more uh than most people can imagine would she ever go
on record and talk about this yeah probably wow i'd love to speak with her yeah this is so it's
so amazing so this is why i always lend to the spiritual side um uh you know i believe that if
there's what is an angel it's a messenger i don't know what it is i know that it is to me it's
uh
it's
And it could be just a fractal of consciousness itself, which that word means God.
And it comes back to the creation or the creator, that mind.
So maybe these lights are just fractals of that, but I don't know.
Do you believe Tim Taylor is a time traveler?
Well, I'm guessing, you know, people say that, but it's possible.
It's very possible.
We were talking right before we were rolling about intersection points, points where maybe you can hop between timelines or something.
What does that mean to you?
Well, you know, it's just hard to wrap your head around.
There's no words for that.
The vocabulary for all this is just like very small.
But yeah, I'll have to think on that one, what it means.
I was having a dream the other.
Night about that, about timelines changing, shifting.
And it was such a weird dream, but it was like, you know, it's like there's stories.
This is really random, but like Bill Murray, the actor, he'll walk around New York City and he'll like take a French fry from somebody, eat it, you know, in their restaurant or whatever.
And, you know, it was just like literally like off the street.
And then they'll look at him.
They'll be like, that's Bill Murray, like taking my fry or whatever.
And then he'll look at them and he'll go, no one will ever believe you.
And that's what a lot of the phenomenon feels like.
It feels like self-concealing, you know, it's like the perfect, I'm sure the perfect amount of the video that you described was cut off where open-minded people will believe it.
And then some hyper skeptic will not.
And there's it's it's like there is always some little stigma left on the evidence that you do have that is fully debunkable.
But it's.
It's always like this.
Like a phenomenon.
That's the phenomenon.
It is.
It's messing.
And it's designed is doing that because there are three kinds of people.
Hmm.
Now, I've talked about this many times.
There are three types.
Yes.
Probably more.
OK.
But there are people that can see.
Right.
They can see this.
There are people that I can teach to see.
Hmm.
And there are people that can never say.
Oh, damn.
They'll never see it because they're skeptical.
And when you're skeptical about this, you will never be in the club ever.
It will not let you in because it doesn't want to mess with your free will.
But skepticism is also good.
Yeah.
But some skeptics can come seers.
Right.
Sure.
But there are some that can never.
Their brains are wired, you know, to where it's a block.
You do need some filtering mechanism.
You need some something in your brain.
You have to.
That feels wrong or false.
Right.
What's the phrase?
You know, your mind can be so open, your brain can fall out.
Yeah.
Right.
So how do you view that?
Because discernment seems like an important, you know, part of wading your way through this topic.
20 years of it.
19 years of me when it first happened.
All I know is that I was afraid when I was looking at it in the broad daylight.
It came out of the sky in daytime.
It wasn't.
It wasn't a dream and it wasn't at night.
It was in the broad daylight.
And they came and they took me.
So that program to me in a way there was never doubting, ever doubting.
Describe this whole experience.
So you said broad daylight and they came and took you.
Who's they?
Well, they, whoever they are.
Yeah.
And this is in my book, UFO of God, by the way.
Check it out.
I haven't plugged it yet.
Yeah.
It was 19 years ago on January the 8th of 2007, will be 19 years.
I was down and out and lost everything, lost my home, my income.
I had too many houses on the market.
I was building 100 homes a year and had been for 19, 20 years.
And the World Trade Center thing happened and then the housing bubble bust.
And so I found myself in a place.
So where I was living in a million dollar home on the golf course, and now I'm in a mobile
home with no income and I'm having to apply for free lunch for my kids.
That's how bad it got.
And so I'm crying out to God, walking along, I had gone fishing at the river with my son
and three other guys and they wanted to fish.
And so I walked away, they were sitting on the bank of the Cape River River.
And I walked up the way we came in, we were down in the bottom, you know, you cross a
big cornfield and then you go down in the river bottom.
So that about a quarter mile down in the bottom is where they were sitting on the bank.
And I told them, I'm going to walk up to the field and look for deer or whatever, just
wildlife.
Not telling them how depressed I was and where I was, I mean, I was struggling bad, sick
with Crohn's disease.
Yeah.
And I had it 18 years suffering with it.
And anyhow, I walk up to that field and it was just about 10 after five when I started
up that way.
It took about five minutes to walk, maybe eight.
And when I got to the top of that hill, there they were, two of these big balls of fire,
like flaming 40 foot round, red, orange, glowing balls of fire.
And the fire is going around.
And these little tips were shooting off of it, flames.
And there were two of them side by side, very low down, probably a couple of hundred feet
above the trees and about 300 yards away.
And I'm at the back of the field and they're up at the road, the highway, you know, that's
where they were.
And I'm sitting there looking at them, scared to death.
First I was mesmerized, like what in the world?
I'm a commercial pilot.
Still have my tickets.
I'm a military pilot.
And so I knew right away what we were looking at wasn't anything Fort Bragg or any military
anybody had.
And so the chill came over me.
It's like, oh, my God, what am I looking at?
So this is my mind went from amazement to fear suddenly.
And then I guess five, 10 minutes sitting there watching it, I got so afraid I wanted
to run.
So I turned my body and pointed down the hill to go run down to where my son was.
And I'm trying to get up.
I'm trying to get up.
My son was on the bank of the river, and I had to look back one more time.
So I turned to look back before I went to run, and when I did, the third one, a third one above me was invisible.
It was not visible.
It just appeared and shot right straight down in front of me.
5.15, 5.30 in the evening in January.
It's not dark.
Four hours later, I come walking back to the river where they were, and my son was missing.
He wasn't there.
He had gotten lost looking for me on foot.
I couldn't compute any of that.
How I had been gone for 20 minutes is all I could think, and they were fussing at me.
Where have you been?
We've been looking at you all night.
It took me a long time to recognize.
I couldn't reconcile that, and then my Crohn's was gone.
I had no more sickness, and if anybody has Crohn's, knows how bad that is.
It's the worst thing.
You're in the restroom 10 times a day.
I was at 20 times a day at that point in my life.
So I'm suffering with sickness and suffering mentally and depressed and finding all of it.
I'm at the very bottom crying out, Lord, help me.
What do I do?
You're living in a relatively small town.
A small town in North Carolina where you were very successful and known by all your community members,
and you were at the depths of despair and, I'm sure, feeling like a pariah or something among your community.
Oh, yeah.
I came back excited to tell it, and that's when basically the next five years of darkness I talk about in my book started.
The pitchforks came out.
The holy water came out, and the social services came to my house trying to remove me from the house.
But real quick, so you said that you thought it was 20 minutes had gone by.
It was four hours.
It was four hours, and do you remember what you had experienced?
Did you recover the memory?
I recovered quite a bit of them.
How did you recover them?
A time, and through hypnosis and a doctor from Harvard helping me.
Okay.
You got to wonder, is it all real?
But I can tell you, they talk telepathically.
Who's the doctor from Harvard?
Dr. Michael O'Connell was his name.
And has he done this with other experiences?
Yeah.
He was trained by John Mack.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
I didn't know there was a doctor at Harvard currently who was trained by, so John Mack
was the head of the Harvard psychiatry department who saw a lot of experiencers, and originally
he got into it because he was interested in missing time.
Right.
It's like all these people are coming with missing time, and then he had been
childhood friends, synchronistically, with Bud Hopkins, who was very interested in experiencers,
abductees.
So he has an air at Harvard, John Mack, does Michael O'Connell.
Well, he's dead now.
He died.
Oh, that's unfortunate.
I was literally going to be like, I want to interview him.
Yeah.
He was a lovely guy.
I mean, we bonded really close until he died.
He lived in South Carolina, so I lived an hour and a half from him, so we visited a
lot.
Wow.
I think another thing for people to understand, if they are skeptical of something coming
out in a hypnotic regression, these experiences are so traumatic.
They're so foreign to you when they happen.
If you look at any other extremely traumatizing experience, just in the world, a woman who's
or somebody experiences child abuse or something extremely serious that just shatters your
whole being, you will repress that memory, and it will often have, you know, you'll have
fragments of it, you'll have shards of it, but it'll be like broken glass, and you'll
need techniques like this at times to recover those memories.
So this guy, Michael O'Connell, works with you, and what do you end up recovering?
Well, what he did, I'll give you a short on what he did.
He came and he started.
Just dialogue, talking, and told me that he knew from his studies that they can tend
to pack a lot of information in your mind, and it's locked away in there, and that if
you were to remember it all at one time, it'd probably drive you crazy.
So he, I can tell you, I had severe headaches if I tried to think past that missing person.
I would pass out.
I did it over and over.
When they would question me, I'd get to a point and I couldn't think anymore, and the
headaches would come so bad.
I would pass out.
You know, there's a really great book by, my mind's just going to all these crazy places,
but there's a book called Healing Back Pain by Paul Sarno.
It's this amazing book that healed a lot of people's backs psychosomatically, because
it talks about chronic pain as being adaptive from a psychological point of view.
Psychosomatic perspective.
And so maybe even this was the case with your Crohn's disease that you were facing, where
it is more adaptive to feel physical pain at times than to process emotional pain.
And so it would make sense that actually physical pain would be the blocker for something that
was maybe more emotionally painful or transformative or something.
Makes sense.
Yeah.
So, so we started working together and he would tell me,
we're going to, we're going to program you to where that all this information comes out
little at a time, not too much, but you'll remember it all.
That's what he said.
Immediately when he did work with me, within days, I started having these nightmares and
dreaming and speaking in my sleep and talking to my wife and kids were videoing me into bed.
They'd hear me, you know, saying all kinds of crazy things.
About my experience and, but what, what it was like, Jesse, it was like a virtual tour.
In other words, they took me, the first thing I remembered was seeing Egypt.
Why?
Over the pyramids, looking over the pyramids and seeing the Sphinx.
That's all I remember that and seeing this temple, Hathor's temple and all the animals and the birds.
It was just like this video that was playing in my brain about.
Yeah.
So I, I, you know, I studied everything I could study about that.
I went to, to scholars like Dr.
Gilbert and learn from Robert, all kinds of sacred geometry.
And I didn't know you learned from Robert Gilbert.
Yeah.
He lived in Nashville, right close to me.
So famous Rosicrucian scholar.
Yeah.
Interesting.
Love the guy.
Wow.
Yeah.
He was very sad.
He, uh, was I think a nuclear chemist and he just passed away.
He passed away from cancer very recently, like this year, I believe.
Yeah.
This year, but a world of knowledge and he helped me a lot, um, understanding the symbols I saw about Egypt.
And then, you know, 2019 comes along.
I write about this in my book.
Um, I'm sick with rheumatoid arthritis now, and I'm been on chemotherapy for like six, seven years.
I'm down to 150 some pounds.
I was walking on a cane and now I'm migrating to a wheelchair.
That's where I was in 2019.
Diana and Tim were in the Vatican archives in 2017.
And I was supposed to go with them, but it couldn't, I was sick and they were, oh, you were supposed to go on that trip.
Well, that could have been arranged.
Yeah.
It was all about me.
The, the whole thing, when they went there, they had a ceremony in the Vatican.
It was supposed to be a ceremony for you.
Yeah.
They had a ceremony.
They put my picture in the picture of the Pope on the outside of the archives.
And then they placed my photo between the books of Galileo and Copernicus.
Really?
Yeah.
To be there forever.
No way.
Yeah, sure did.
Do you have, you have photos of this?
I did.
Could you send that?
Wow.
This is amazing.
Yeah.
So, so, and who was, was Tim Taylor prompting them to do this ceremony or.
I think Diana's connection to the.
The Vatican and this, the lady I speak about, you know, I, here, I come in 20, um, 12 having an experience with this lady, this beautiful, glowing lady that, um, boy, that was something too, because that was at the end of five years and I was fighting the government, the social services for my sanity.
Yeah.
Um.
But real quick.
So, cause you were describing your first experience that.
Right.
You know, O'Connell helped you get.
Get out.
And so you're, you're around the pyramids.
You've, you see, you see the sacred geometry, which, you know, uh, Dr.
Uh, uh, Robert Gilbert helps you kind of decode.
Right.
Did you decode anything?
Did you, did you notice any sort of messaging?
Yeah, I did.
I started seeing likeness and their, the, the way they portray their deities is, um, and the whole matrix of the thing, you know, it's like when Jesus was born, it said, uh, an
angel came and said, go to Egypt.
Right.
Well, we don't realize that Egypt was controlled by Greece for 500 years before that.
So perfect fit for him to go there and to grow up there.
And when you start seeing the similarities between the two, there's pretty much the same thing.
And, and there's stories between, yeah, between the Trinity, Jesus and the Trinity.
And then.
Ra and Horus and the whole thing, they have a triad, triad there.
Right.
But their, their deities are, um, portrayed as animals, birds, forces of nature.
This is what Dr.
Gilbert spoke about.
Uh, it's all about everything, nature and humanity.
And so, and then you read the story of Ezekiel and the wheel within the wheel, right?
He walks.
Between two of the cherubim.
It says, and he walked between them and there he met an angel.
Right.
And what was it had places of animals and only one part human.
So it's, it's, it's not like grandma with wings and a beautiful robe, right?
It's just, these things are creatures and they're, it's always, um, did you see these creatures?
No, I only, I've studied them.
Okay.
All right.
I saw.
The creatures.
Yeah.
I drew them.
When they were, um, little glowing beings about this tall, but those seem more of the variety of the extraterrestrials or aliens people kind of experience.
Well, they say that until you read Daniel chapter 10, when it talks about an angel that he saw.
And when I described this little being, I said, he looked like glass.
He was shot so shiny.
His whole body was glowing.
Like he had a suit on that was gleaming like glass.
You see this.
Alien in the.
In the craft or.
I saw it standing from me to you, from me.
And this was in the, on the, in like the woods.
Yeah.
Near your house.
And I, I wrote about this and, um.
And he had a little triangle.
Triangle on his chest.
Yeah.
Funny.
There's a triangle right there, right?
Oh, there you go.
I was thinking that when you were like, look at my little pendant.
I was like, well, was that an homage to the triangle from the alien being?
That was from NASA.
And two.
I have multiple.
I have multiple videos and, and if we go sky watching at some point, you'll see the
phenomena will always try to line up in a triangle or in threes.
Interesting.
So it's like a, maybe the trinity or something.
Yeah.
It's telling us something, right?
What is that?
I, I don't know.
I'm, it's all speculation.
I'm learning.
What else did Robert Gilbert tell you?
Because he did seem like a person who was very tapped into.
Oh yeah.
Kind of deeper esoteric truths.
Yeah.
A lot.
I learned a lot from him.
That.
That helped me understand that this world is so far more complex.
Uh, for example, um, he described pendulums.
If you go to Egypt and you dig in the soil there, the most artifacts that they find under
the ground in Egypt are pendulums.
Is that true?
Yeah.
That's the most frequent artifact.
That's the most frequent.
They find the millions of them.
And so he explained to me what they knew and how the, the people that
set Washington up, they did the same thing.
Why they have an obelisk in Washington.
Why they have one in central park.
Why is there one in France and in England they have, and they went to Egypt and got
those things and brought them back and stood those stones up.
Well, you know, uh, if you look at, uh, Charles Launfant, you have all this kind
of free Masonic symbolism around DC, and that is definitely derived from ancient
Egypt.
In fact, I've been inside of this like free Masonic temple in DC.
And, and by the way, I'm not a free Mason and I wouldn't be saying
this if it was obviously.
Um, but like, it's, it's just, you might as well be in like an
Egyptian temple or something.
It's all Egyptian symbology.
And so you think there's like a link between, I think there's, it's a big
mystery, but there's a link some, yeah, some way or another.
Wow.
Yeah.
So interesting.
And then the other connection for you with ancient Egypt is, so you're around
the pyramids and you see these symbols, but, and then you obviously encounter
these beings, but later you encounter the lady.
Right.
And she describes herself as Hathor.
Is that right?
Well, that was one name.
She is, she, she said she had many names and, um, she had been called many
things throughout the world.
In other words, Diana, Demeter, Isis, Hathor, Hera.
Um, the Virgin Mary, everything.
She's had many names throughout history and by every culture.
And the way she explained it to me helped me understand a religion in a
different way, how people conceive, you know, like the, the, the Taoist or the,
the Muslims or the, the Catholics or whoever, uh, only imagine God in their
minds.
We all do.
We imagine that and it turns into an ugly thing because religions tend to
think they have the skivvy on God.
And therefore we going to go to war with you because you don't believe like us.
That's, that's the problem that has to stop.
This is the message she told me that she had many names throughout history and
that God is God and we don't know what we think we know, and we need to set back.
And reanalyze and, you know, be good children and, or we're going off the
cliff and that's kind of the thing she told me.
And she told me about the missiles that was in 2012, but, um, it was so much
there, I came out of the, in 2012 telling it like right away, what that, what
that she explained to me.
And you received a prophecy about 2026 as well, right?
Yeah.
And what was that?
Well, she said, um, and I had no idea what it meant.
Still don't other than she said that when the star of Regulus, which is a blue
star, when it appears red on the horizon at the dawn, uh, before the sun comes up
and the gaze of the Spanx, in other words, I saw it in a vision, the whole thing to
see the Spanx facing east.
And this thing's just.
Cresting the top.
She said, when that happens, that will, uh, be a sign that ushers in a new
knowledge for humanity.
So does that mean the return of Jesus or the return of, uh, Christ consciousness?
It could, and I, uh, think that's possible.
Uh, but it's, it's, it marks a sign.
She said to where the, the, the darkness would be exposed and
the truth would be revealed.
Mm-hmm so I think we're gonna learn something over the next couple of years
that, you know, and this was 12 years ago.
I said this 13 years ago, 2012.
Yeah.
Right.
And how, when these missiles started flying and the orb started appearing, that
got a lot of attention on me real quick.
Yeah.
I'm it's funny.
I'm caught between two minds.
One is, you know, I think even the book of Matthew, it's something like nobody knows
today other than God.
Right.
Uh, paraphrasing, but yeah, nobody knows the day.
Um, and then on the other hand, it does feel like just this gestalt sense of like
things are getting weirder.
Yeah.
Dark truths are being revealed ongoing.
It feels like it's already started.
Um, and it feels like we're on the verge of, uh, uh, some sort of paradigm shift.
Yeah, we are definitely.
Yeah.
I agree with that a hundred.
And I, I think everybody sees something coming and.
Uh, uh.
A new knowledge just coming and a new shift that, um, things that I know that, um, imagine
a world without oil.
Hmm.
So you think we're going to have free energy at some point soon or something?
Imagine the world without rockets.
Right.
So that kind of knowledge alone would change everything.
All of humanity.
And so that's in our future.
Well, that was Thomas Townsend Brown's vision, you know, a world.
Beyond rockets that, you know, he had this model of electrogravitics, which connected electromagnetism and gravity, which, you know, in kind of our standard physics is, you know, we don't have a link between those two things.
Right.
And, uh, if you were to get a link, if the input was pure electromagnetism or, you know, electrical and the output was some sort of gravity, gravitational perturbation, um, that, that, that would be paradigm shifting.
Exactly.
I mean, you'd get well beyond what SpaceX is, which.
Is extremely inefficient.
You know, most of, I believe the, the Starship, their latest rocket is, I think it's 5,000 metric tons and a, an extremely high percentage of that.
I mean, the payload capacity of it is like 150 tons.
So that ratio alone, it's all fuel.
The whole thing is fuel.
That's not efficient.
That's not alien interstellar space travel.
It doesn't make sense.
Well, I imagine a day that we won't need those things.
Hmm.
In fact, they probably already.
Would have had that.
Do you think they did?
I think so.
Really?
I think it's possible.
So why not?
Cause why not let it out then?
Because it, it would change everything.
It could, it could create a, it's something that has to be given slowly.
It's too disruptive.
Too disruptive.
Yeah.
I imagine.
It would definitely be destabilizing for institutions.
Exactly.
You know, if you had say right now we're paying, I'm just gonna throw fake numbers out there, but.
50.
$15, you know, per kilowatt hour for electricity or whatever.
If that reduced to 10 cents per kilowatt hour, a whole lot of institutions would kind of crumble.
Corporations would experience a lot of like for the people who are like there, it wouldn't, you know, destabilize things.
I think that's crazy.
I think it would.
I think it'd be very positive.
Well, it would be in the end, but imagine the oil tankers, the thousands of them are refineries and all the jobs that's involved.
Sure.
With it.
So.
Sure.
Yeah.
But then the, imagine the abundance on the other side.
All of those people, their quality of life of life would be dramatically.
Different.
You know, better.
Yeah.
So, so is that the new knowledge?
I don't know, but I think that is a, is a, there's a whole lot of things that are going to come forward that have been hidden from us.
And the main thing is the truth that we're not alone.
Yeah.
I mean that, well, that's clear to me, you know?
I think that's, that's definitely a thing.
And so I believe next year we'll be closer to that than ever.
Yeah.
And the word apocalypse, by the way, you know what that means?
Unveiling.
Yeah.
To reveal a secret.
To reveal the secret.
Yeah.
That's all.
And people think when you hear that, and if you look on Google, it says the ultimate destruction, the end, you know, it's lying to us.
That's not what the word means at all.
It means to reveal that which has been hidden.
And it's, it's the veil thinning.
And I think for some people that will be very good and for other people will be very bad.
It depends on your orientation to it.
Right.
And I think it does have this connotation of, you know, the Beezlebub coming down and breathing fire onto everybody, sorting people and whatever.
But like, I think if you were oriented in a, in a good way, spiritually, you know, I don't think it'll necessarily be bad for you.
I also don't even, you know, we're talking about it.
Like it's one, you know, crazy event with these like divine beings.
Maybe it's like a slow moving.
That's exactly the way I see it.
It's not like snap your fingers and something.
We're not going to wake up on Easter or whenever that time happens.
Yeah.
I'm torn by the way, because for eight years I wrote and talked about this alignment being in September or somewhere in the fall.
Cause that was the date given to me by some people into astrology.
And then they come back right when I go to write my book and say, oh, we made a mistake.
It said Easter.
And I thought, well, that sounds plausible because the lady's always coming around Easter.
I have this and saying experiences every year at Easter.
Are you still having them?
Yeah.
That's amazing.
So you still speak every year and you think it's the same, the Virgin Mary, Hathor, Demeter, you think all of these, I think it's the Sophia, the wisdom, the Holy Spirit.
Yeah.
It would be kind of the Gnostic version or something.
That's who I think this being is.
It was a spirit and it was definitely holy in her presence.
And so, and she physically impacted me because the wind blew me backwards to the ground.
It was such a blast of wind that blew me down.
And I started researching that.
And the word spirit is the wind.
Right.
And the word Holy Spirit is the breath of God.
But it was the wind that affected me and the power from it.
This cow came over me, but the wind pushed me back.
What does she look like?
Looked like the most beautiful 35, 40-year-old woman you've ever seen.
Just glowing and typical Virgin Mary apparition type thing.
And, you know, this thing, this spirit appears in every country.
It appeared to the Native Americans in the Wild West back, you know, they called her the white buffalo calf lady.
The Egyptians called her Hathor and earlier before met.
And the birth mother, the creator in Proverbs in the Bible, chapter 8 and 9 talks about wisdom.
It's the name of the chapters.
And it talks about, and she was created before the earth was created, before the beginning.
And she was created at the end of time.
Wow.
So who is she?
I don't know.
But that's my thought.
What was the feeling that came over you when you saw her, when you see her regularly?
It's, when I first saw her, it was very impactful because the cow ran me over.
So I had this extreme fright to start with.
And then I land on my back and I roll over to get up and run.
And there's this beautiful woman.
So I went from extreme fear.
Fear to, oh my God, what is this in front of me?
Is the cow running you over part of the whole thing?
That was part of the, her coming at me.
She came at me at night out of the darkness as a wind, the wind hit me.
And as I'm going backwards to the ground, I see a translucent cow run over top of me and I could see stars up through the thing.
I'm like, oh my God.
And I, and I was frightened so bad.
I landed on my back and I turned to get up and run.
And there's this woman about.
I'm here to that camera, three feet off the ground hovering.
And she looked at me and she said, you know why I'm here.
And I'll tell you why she said that because five years had gone by 2007 to 2012.
And I had been beaten down and broken by the community.
My children were falling apart.
The schools and the teachers were calling them to the side.
Is your dad crazy?
We hear about all this.
Are you all right?
Somebody from there called social services on me and I had to fight to be at home with my children.
It was that bad.
So five years of that, I walked out on Easter, Saturday night, Easter of 2012, Sunday morning's Easter, right?
And I shouted to this guy, thank you for saving me.
Thank you for healing me, but you've ruined my life.
Now my children are affected and not, and I have caused them great harm.
And, and I'll never speak about this again.
Even though I had the desire, they put this in me, like the famous movie, Close Encounters, where you see, he's making a mashed potato mountain on his, in dirt, and he's throwing it in the wind and bushes and he's creating devil's sour, right?
He didn't know what it was, but it was in his head.
So I was that guy I had to tell everybody.
And the more I told it, the more trouble I got myself into.
And what you're referencing with your father.
Yeah.
His family is junior, your son who had gone looking for you also saw beings, was really shocked at what he experienced.
It was the community that caused him to want to leave home.
Really?
Yeah.
He was 17 years old and my right hand, it was with me everywhere I went and we come home telling the world about it.
And now the whole community has come on us.
And so five years into it.
I'm out telling the heavens, I quit.
I'll never talk about it again.
And then she appears and says, you know why I'm here.
This is your burden.
You must bear.
You have to tell what you know.
And if you do, I will allow you to video record and fill my presence and share it with others.
The lady said that.
She told me that.
And are you going to?
Well, let me tell you from 2007 to 2012, I had zero data.
I was out every night with a camera trying to get pictures to save myself from the community, right?
The more I tried, the less it would let me film it.
It'd be hovering in the trees behind my house.
I pull the camera out and it would vanish every time.
So I was angry about that.
I'm trying to prove myself sane.
And my child is now left home because the community has just been tough.
So.
Um, she's like, you're not going to quit.
I'm going to help you.
So from that point forward, I started being able to film it and sharing it with anybody.
And I've amassed terabytes and terabytes of data, video, photo, audio, and, um, never a picture until 2012 when she came.
Why do you think these guys from NASA are showing up at your door?
We mentioned Tim Taylor earlier.
He's a NASA mission controller.
Hal Pauvenmeier also showed up originally.
And I think you, Ryan, your son mentioned that kind of at the end of his life, you realized that he was both CIA and NASA.
Yeah.
And so what do you think their interest in all of this is?
Um, and there are a lot more NASA guys.
That was just two of them.
Really?
In fact, I had dinner with Hal's wife this weekend.
She came from Florida to, uh, Chris Jr's wedding.
Oh.
Oh, wow.
Yeah.
We love them.
And, uh, but there are a lot of other NASA guys that I'm currently talking with.
Several.
One tells me wherever I go, but they're all interested.
They tail you wherever you go.
They're there with me.
Really?
Yeah.
Usually traveling with me.
Somebody associated with that.
Yeah.
What do you think they want?
They all want to study it.
They want to know, and they observe it with me.
They, I take them out and we, you know, we do a lot of work.
Are they with you in Austin, Texas?
Well, nobody wanted to be, I only have one night and my wife's friend traveled
with me cause she was at our house and her kids are right down the street.
Uh-huh.
But, uh, usually I go nowhere without somebody with me for a reason.
Wow.
Yeah.
I've had some things that, that, um, caused me to want to have somebody with me all the time.
What happened that caused you to want to not leave?
You know, cause you to want to leave.
Yeah.
You don't want to go anywhere unaccompanied.
Um, well, I've been threatened a few times by different ones and, uh, was at the PSI games
this year, PSI games, I call it PSI, PSI games, and, um, came out of a conference speaking
and when I walked out the door, this mad lady comes running up to me and tries to kidnap
me.
What?
Yeah.
Has something with drugs on it.
Tried to get me in a van with no driver, with no tags on it and security had to come.
They had to call the law on her.
Yeah.
So crazy, crazy people.
I, I imagine you attract a lot of nutty people.
Big time.
What do you think the Vatican knows about all of this?
If they had a picture of you and they were doing some ceremony about you and you were supposed to come, what do you think they think of you?
Well, I can share a couple of photos of you for that, but, um, I got three pictures, several, quite a few.
Paintings that they have in the Vatican that Diana sent me from there and Pope Francis, uh, she said to tell me that they know that they're angels, that, uh, they don't mean to harm us, but their energy, if they get excited, can cause harm to a human.
So just be careful and try to ask it not to get too close to you.
And these three photos or paintings show.
Orbs with angels in them.
That's what they told me.
Yeah.
Because, you know, you have St.
Francis of Assisi who she writes about in 13th century, Mount Laverne in Italy, brother Leo's right next to him.
And he sees this, uh, angel.
But if you look at the original Greek translation, it's a flaming torch.
She thinks it's this UFO experience and that the stigmata he receives these wounds on his hands are actually electromagnetic damage.
Um, that like, you know, Gary Nolan or somebody studying kind of modern experiencers interacting with UFOs might just say, oh, that's like an electromagnetic burn, or you let you see it in close encounter of the third kind.
You see the burn on his face.
I got, I got, um, yeah, I got radiation burns, plasma radiation.
That's what NASA told me.
It was the, uh, so you got, you also got plasma radiation burns.
No, I didn't.
But I was warned a million times by how Papa Meyer and.
Different ones at NASA kept calling me, honestly, over and over.
Don't let them get too close.
Don't get too close to them.
The, how I was telling me that they knew the voltage was like 33 million volts in one of these things.
And if it got near me, it would kill me dead.
So they have like a scientific model of how these angels work at NASA.
They know a lot more than we know than we think they do.
They just don't share it.
Right.
So who is this like team?
Uh, like between CIA and NASA that knows a lot about angels.
Well, I don't know that, but I know the, the NRO is the ones that have the keys to this thing.
Really?
And why do you think that?
Cause they have the keys to all the satellites and all the eyes on the sky.
And they're the ones that every rocket, when it goes up, right.
They observe every aspect of that rocket for reasons for mechanical reasons and.
For a surprise visit that happens pretty much every time they launch one.
Do you think that rockets attract UFOs?
That's what I'm saying.
Every time they send one up, it attracts them and they'll come up and look at it.
If it has weapons on board.
Does Tim Taylor know Elon Musk?
Yeah.
Do they work together?
Um, for sure.
Yeah.
Did Tim ever tell you that?
Well, he mentioned his name, but he didn't say he worked for him, but he controls all the launches.
Controls.
All.
All the launches.
Tim does.
He's the launch guy.
He's, he's the dragon.
His console is called dragon control.
And he controls all of the launches out of Cape Canaveral or.
He's the guy.
He's the one.
And I'll tell you what he does.
When they fire a rocket up, right.
They have these big ground-based cameras, like on a World War II, um, battleship where they sit on a gun and they could turn a handle and the gun would go around and, you know, the.
They could control this thing they're sitting on.
Well, they have big binoculars on it like that, and they can get on this thing and follow this rocket up and they got it to about 50,000 feet.
Then it gets blurry.
So at that point, it's intercepted by a WB 57 run out of Houston by a good friend of mine, which is national reconnaissance office works with Taylor.
So his crews up there at 50,000 feet and it intercepts the rocket.
So they film it with seven cameras on that thing, where it goes right on up when it gets up to a hundred thousand feet, then it's intercepted by F one Oh four starfighter equipped with another seven or eight cameras on that.
And so it trails it right on up until it runs out of sight of, and then the satellites take it over.
And the only ones that can look at the satellites are these NRO guys.
And Tim walks out of his control into a private room.
Yeah.
Where all the screens are.
So his eyes are on all that.
Fascinating.
Yeah.
How did he get into that line of work?
Because if you read launch fever, I don't think he's traditionally credentialed or trained.
Well, my friend from Houston told me he helped him get that position.
And who's your friend from Houston?
I can't say.
Okay.
He lives right down the road from here on a big, on a big ranch right out here.
Yeah.
Well, I'd love to meet him.
We can figure it out.
I'll show you a picture of him later.
Okay, cool.
Um, wow.
Fascinating.
And, um, cause Tim also works at aerospace corporation, right?
Yeah.
And what do you think the link is between NASA and aerospace corporation?
I know a lot of those guys are NRO.
Okay.
Interesting.
And they carry blackberries everywhere.
They go.
Blackberries.
Yeah.
Not iPhones, androids.
They have all that, but they have blackberries.
They do their business.
Hmm.
Do you think he's a time traveler?
I think it's entirely possible.
I, you know, honestly, I, I can tell you a story about him.
Yeah.
It's in my book.
Um, I think it made it in, uh, I wrote 140,000 words and we only published 85 and that was what they recommended the, for the right size of book.
Right.
So, but in one of the stories I talk about Tim.
After we came back from Zanesville.
Ohio, he came to my house and, uh, we had this famous tree on my yard that caught fire.
This is a video out on the internet.
You can see Chris Bledsoe burning tree.
Well, we had his tree that just spontaneously combusted in the backyard.
It rained for two days, grounds, wet, everything's wet.
And, uh, my wife and I walk out the back door at nine o'clock and this poof, it erupted into flames and was shooting 20, 15 feet up.
Yeah.
Through the tree.
And, uh, she put it out three times with a hose pipe.
It kept reigniting itself.
And, uh, so that got the attention of everybody and Tim wanted to see this tree.
So he's at my house come, I picked him up at the airport.
He goes to my daughter's homecoming game that night.
She was a little homecoming princess in the 10th grade.
Now she's a, has a double masters from NYU.
So that's been a long time ago.
Right.
We walk up to this.
This tree and having just a good, you know, conversation.
And all of a sudden the one side of the tree is open where it burnt from the inside, the tree caught fire in the inside and burnt a hole through the side of the tree.
And when we walked up to it, he walks up and puts his head right up to look up in the tree.
And all of a sudden this snake comes out of the tree, this silver snake.
And it was perfectly, I never seen anything like it ever.
It was silver.
It was a silver automobile, perfect color.
He jumps back and he grasps for air.
Oh my God.
Just like that.
He looks at me and he was short with words.
And he said, uh, he said, you know, my grandmother is full-blooded Choctaw,
Indian, and I went to, to, um, school on a minority grant.
My grandma told me if I ever saw a silver snake, it was part of their, their
history, right?
She said it would be a message from God.
And he saw that and told me all about it.
But I watched his reaction and it got the best of him when that snake come out of that tree.
And you saw the snake.
I was standing beside him.
Yeah.
What do you think the message could have been from God?
It was a message from him for him to understand this whole thing was from God somehow or another.
Mm.
And how does one of the most interesting things?
Yeah.
Wonder is if you read American cosmic or talk to Diana Pasolka, it's almost like they visited the Vatican archives.
He figured out a way in before she had gotten there.
And then they were sort of celebrating him at the Vatican observatory.
Like why would the Vatican observatory know who a random NASA mission controller is?
It makes me think he is not a random NASA mission controller.
He's not a random guy at all.
He's, um, let's just say.
He runs with the biggest.
How so?
Do you think he has a connection with the president?
Yeah, absolutely.
He briefed, he briefed Obama on me.
That's where this come from.
He briefed Obama on you.
It came from him with a dinner napkin from Camp David, Maryland.
And you're sure of that?
Positive.
And did he tell you that he briefed Obama?
No, he didn't tell me that, but I know that's what it means.
Because of the, the, the, uh, letterhead.
Yeah.
And where it came from.
Bob McGuire, who is, I think, former Intel and a friend of yours came on the show.
And he said, I, I, that, that cannot be faked.
Right.
That definitely came from Camp David.
Yeah.
It's a napkin and an envelope with a napkin, partially obscuring
the address that's on the envelope.
I knew the address because it was the address of Chris Bledsoe.
I knew the napkin because it was the presidential seal on a napkin from Camp David.
There's only.
There's only one way you can have that napkin because it's a crime to copy the presidential seal.
There's only one person that can get you to Camp David.
And the picture was mailed to him by Tim Taylor.
By Tim Taylor.
And the only person at that story can have been told to in that envelope was Barack Obama.
Oh, my God.
The letter.
To me is ironclad proof that Chris's story was taken all the way to Barack Obama via Tim Taylor.
Yes.
You might think he was trying to throw you off the trail.
If he said, I briefed the president and was bragging or whatever, but he didn't sound it out.
Independent.
Right.
I found it out.
I didn't know what it meant, but I knew that it, uh, he told me he just returned from Camp David and it was at Christmas when he told you that.
Yeah.
And he said, I was at the dinner table with.
The president and handed me that, uh, he said that, yeah.
Okay.
So he did tell you that, but he didn't tell me he briefed him, but he did give me the napkin and the, and this, yeah.
And you believe him.
Yeah.
Had no reason not to, you know, have you ever caught him in a lie?
No, ever.
Uh, I wouldn't know.
Not that I can recall.
Everything he said has either come out to be true or you're waiting for confirmation.
Right.
Wow.
Have you independently verified.
Some of them.
What are you telling me?
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
Is there an example of that?
Uh, no, but it's just, you know, it'd be like, it's just so hard to pinpoint any one thing.
Sure.
Or like, I don't know, some of the things about how the NRO or NASA work together.
Have you been able to verify it?
Yeah, absolutely.
Yeah.
Do you think that the big dipper or Ursa major has anything to do with the UFO phenomenon?
You've said that you've seen UFOs come from.
That constellation specifically.
I have a, yeah, but you know, I've learned since then it, it, that doesn't matter.
It's wherever I look, I can take you out at night and face one certain direction and only have a hole to look through that direction and it'll come from there.
We can turn in any direction and focus there.
And that's where it'll come from.
So do you, do you think the Vatican.
And the president and whoever Tim Taylor, you know, the, the hammer, do you think they're all coordinating in some way, like maybe this archangel, the Vatican and the president, or what do you think the connection is there?
I don't have a clue.
I'm just telling you what I was told.
Right.
Yeah.
So, and I've been told a lot of things, but he told me about the movie, the adjustment Bureau and the story about the hammer.
Have you ever watched the Netflix show dark by any chance?
No.
I don't know.
Do you think that you, you mentioned, uh, Tim's grandmother being native American.
So is he a time traveler?
I know where he came from, right.
As a young boy, which is, well, he told me the story about his upbringing, his native American grandma.
And so I'm just answering that question you asked earlier.
Is he a time traveler?
I don't know.
I just know he told me and shared with me.
Did he say anything else about Thomas Townsend Brown?
Not a lot other than we went there, we went to, uh, into conversation about his, his, uh, daughter and that he was actively, and I actually have the manuscript saved on my phone.
He shared with me that he was working with her on, on, on this book, on that book, whatever happened to the book.
I don't know, but I know I have the manuscript.
Oh, I would love to read it, whether they were publishing it or ended up publishing it.
I, I don't know if they did or not.
What was it going to be about?
About their father, her father and his work and Tim's input confirming it all.
And Tim definitely knew Townsend Brown.
Yeah.
He knew his daughter.
He caught her when I was there with him.
This is crazy.
Yeah.
This is so interesting.
I want to, are you still in touch with Tim?
I haven't spoke to him.
He sent word to me a couple of years ago.
I want to speak to him about Townsend Brown.
He's a ghost, Tim.
Yeah.
His, his whole life.
I admire him because his real life is in medical saving children, cares more about the children and, and the struggles they have and diseases and cancers and finding cures for that.
I, I'm, I'm sort of.
I'm sort of like a part of me is like hesitant to even ask questions about him because I don't like honing in on any specific individual, but when there's a specific individual who seems like they're embedded at the deepest levels of power structures that go as high as he does, they're claiming things to you and Diana Pasolka that seem kind of otherworldly, you know, I just have to be fascinated and it, and both you and Diana have, you know, public, you know, followings.
Yeah.
And so I'm like, okay, like you have to know, like some of this stuff's going to get out and you're gonna instill curiosity, you know, and I, you know, I don't know if you know this, but I met him once for like 20 minutes.
Oh, you did?
Like a FaceTime or whatever.
Tim?
You did?
Yeah, I met him.
Wow.
It was so stupid in retrospect because now I'd ask him so many other questions.
You were tongue tied at that moment.
Well, not only tongue tied, I was, cause I was invested in this rocket company and they
were struggling to get off the launch pad and I, normally I'd separate the woo woo UFO stuff
entirely from like, you know, that world.
I don't, I, you know, try not to mix them at all, but, uh, I was kind of desperate and
I was like, okay, I, I did read this book, American cosmic.
And I know that like, you know, there's this guy and he claims to use consciousness to
get the rockets off the pad.
And so I'm like, if there's anything there, I know the guys I'm working with, you know,
invested in.
And they're not thinking about consciousness as any sort of factor component.
So that was the impetus for me to talk to him.
And we talked about that for 20 and the trippiest thing he said to me, and I don't
remember exactly how he said it, but it was clear.
This was the implication is he said for you to succeed in your rocket company, like you
have to know what they want, you know?
And like Diana said it, you know, called it the sponsors and that's, you know, but it's
the, the, the beings or whatever.
Now, you know why he has a private office.
And then the only one with eyes on whatever comes up to that rocket.
And he's the only one with eyes on that.
Well, he's the one that he's at, uh, Cape Canaveral in that room.
What, where does the nickname, the dragon come from?
I don't know, but he has a tattoo on his arm of the dragon.
And when I was allowed to get on base, I had to get a tattoo right here.
Just, it was part of the mission.
Really?
And it was of a dragon.
Whoa.
And then you have the dragon capsule.
Uh, you know, at space X and I don't know if that's, do you think that's a coincidence
or no, it was all part of it.
You think so?
Yeah.
Um, when you were at Cape Canaveral, he was showing you around.
Did he show you anything interesting?
Yeah, a lot of stuff, anything exciting or kind of beyond what you would expect just
at a, you know, a normal, I was like a kid right here of the, the most secure place on
the planet, Cape Canaveral, the mission control.
He told me it was more secure than the white house.
Nothing is just that secure.
And last time I talked about this, I got in trouble.
Right.
Really?
Well, yeah.
Uh, one particular thing I mentioned on Danny Jones podcast.
Well, you got in trouble for saying something?
Well, yeah, well, it got, I don't want to say it here because it got his, got it, it, it
got the algorithm killed on that.
You said that, uh, the views were like, you know, it was like doing 50 K a day.
Yeah.
And then it cuts off, you speak to some rep at Google and they're like, we don't know
what the hell happened here.
It doesn't make any sense given the click-through rate average V duration, which should basically
define the video's performance.
He goes, the one other time I've seen this is with Jesse's David Grush video.
Exactly.
Performance fell off a cliff.
Yep.
So, and he said that he said that my video with Bledsoe and your video with Grush, neither
of them broke any YouTube rules or had any internal red flags that he was able to see.
Yep.
And he goes, whenever this happens, which has happened one other time recently with
David Grush, it's basically the floor above me that I have no access to something above
my head that I don't know what the hell's going on.
So what the hell is going on?
Yeah.
Danny Jones said that the video got totally like cut off throttled and he was confused.
And Danny, by the way, is not like a dogmatic UFO believer at all.
It goes back and forth on the whole thing a lot.
And he's apparently called this rep at Google and Google said, you know, the only time this
has ever happened and it's the floor above us and a video's totally gotten nuked was
Jesse Michael's David Grush interview.
Yeah, right.
So.
Well, that happened with me and I put him in touch with my friend in Washington and
the CIA and I said, look, they just killed this.
And he got to the bottom of it.
But he did.
Yeah.
And he figured out that there was actual possible obstruction.
Well, from what I heard was just something I mentioned, got the attention of the news
and the news called NASA and NASA's like, God, we don't want to talk about this.
What?
This is crazy.
Well, because, I mean, Trump just designated NASA as a spy agency.
Well.
And it's already, it's, it's, you're already, you know, you're labeling a thing that's already
been the case for, you know, decades.
Right.
But this is just confirmation of that.
That's what?
Whoa.
That's what happened with that video with Danny.
Still got, what, 1.2 or 3 million views?
That's a whole ton of views.
Do you, do you think that NASA has other propulsion modalities?
I think they've had it a long time.
Really?
I know they were working on it a long time ago because I was asked to, to work on which
way electrons move.
Really?
Yeah.
And what does that mean?
And what, what is it when working on it?
Back engineering machines.
Reverse engineering UFO.
Yeah.
Really?
Yep.
Are the UFOs like alien reproduction vehicles that like hover and then go into space?
Or are they like high voltage chambers that are like portals, like in the movie Contact,
where you end up in some other dimensional space?
I think it's probably both of that exists.
I don't know, but.
And you think NASA is sitting on this stuff?
I don't know.
I don't know that NASA is necessarily, but there are satellite groups that keep it under
wraps.
It is so far buried.
Do you think.
According to Tim, there were two generals at the Pentagon that knew everything.
And which general?
Two.
He didn't tell me.
Interesting.
Air Force generals.
See, when you go to NASA, the mission control, when you walk in there, it's a square building
with a long hallway in the very middle.
And when you walk down this hallway, it's glass.
It's glass on both sides, right?
And you look to the right, here's all NASA scientists and launching, you know, at their
consoles.
And you look to the left, it's exactly the same, but it's all Air Force people.
So they have dual redundancy.
Air Force over here and civilian on this side running every launch.
And Tim's in the middle of all of it.
And then once that rocket goes up, he disappears into this one little room that has eyes on
it.
The whole time.
What was the most interesting thing you saw with your own eyes at Cape Canaveral?
Probably, well, I learned some interesting things that I dare won't share.
Not on here, but I guess going into crew quarters was the greatest thing for me because when
we got there, this building had been built like in the late 50s when they first started
Mercury and launch.
And it was like a mission to the moon, right?
And only, according to Tim, only 300 people had ever been in that building in all those
years, only 300.
And he said, only one president, no congressman, anyone.
And he said, you know, don't go around sharing this because, here I am sharing it, because
they might get upset why they're not allowed in this place.
And those 300 people would include the staff that run the place, the den mother.
That's been there.
I met her.
She'd been there 35 years.
And she has a small group of people.
The doctor that's on, that lives there with the mom, the dad, and the children.
So those 300 people would be John Glenn and Armstrong and their family, right?
So their kids and their wives and all.
So a very small group of people had been in there.
And I got to tour the whole place and sit where the astronauts sit and have a, to sit,
in the boardroom and go in the doctor's offices and sit where they put their spacesuits on.
I got to look through all that and handle it.
It's amazing.
But I was told that when you leave from here, you'll never be the same.
He said that every time that thing went up and when it came back down, something came
with them and was still there.
What came with them?
Well, the, what?
Whatever the spirit is, a phenomenon, something intelligent.
Whoa.
Is there.
Yep.
So like, almost like a hitchhiker tag along effect or something.
They would go up and then they'd come back down, but be, they'd be hitched with some
sort of spiritual thing.
Yeah.
Whoa.
He said that.
He told me that.
And that's why they don't let everybody in there.
And do you, do you, so.
Is your take, cause there's, to me, there's something weird about the moon landing.
I don't think it's necessarily fake, like, you know, not like full hoax or something,
but there's something that's feels very managed about our perception on it.
What do you think actually happened?
That's a big one.
Cause I've learned some things since about that.
I've seen some photos of the moon and, um, some things I can't dare say, but what I saw makes me wonder, is it.
Yeah.
Is it real?
Is it an illusion?
Was it put there?
Tim insinuated that it was, it wasn't there by accident, that it was set there.
That's all he would say.
They're very sly with their words, but I, I, I think that's the case too.
It's title locked.
So you never see the dark side.
It's one 400th the size of the sun, but 400 times closer to the earth from the sun in this sort of perfect way.
And.
The conventional story of how it was made makes no sense to me.
The idea that there was some sort of proto earth and this Mars like object hit earth or whatever, like this massive object hit or part of the earth's mantle came out and firm formed this perfect cylindrical Prima facie.
You don't need to be an expert in this stuff to know that that's probably not the case.
Right.
And then parts of it seem hollow.
There seem to be caverns in it.
They're, you know, they put seismometers on the moon, if you believe the face value story of Apollo 11, even conventional, like nobody can argue with this.
They put, you know, seismometers on the moon and it ring like a bell.
Right.
So, and then I think Gordon McDonald, who's Eisenhower's space advisor said the moon would only make sense if it were hollow or something like that.
It's just a strange, it's a strange object.
It is strange.
And it affects our thoughts.
You think it affects our thoughts?
Absolutely.
It does.
Well, you.
You have this sort of, you know, check it and hide.
You have lunacy, right?
That word lunacy, lunatic.
That's where it came from.
That's right.
If you go to the sheriff's department, the jails fill up on a full moon.
Yeah, it's fair enough.
Yeah.
And I mean, you do, you do have, you know, obviously women's cycles affected by the, by the moon, you know, the idea that it doesn't affect, I don't want to go full astrology necessarily, but you know, the idea that it doesn't affect, you know, ecological processes or biological processes.
That's, that's wrong.
So then what, what is the extent of that effect?
I don't know, but.
Something I saw tends to make me think that, um, that, um, it's an illusion or it's, um, it is something I just can't say without getting.
What do you think it is?
I think something about our soul.
What about the backside of it?
What do you think?
Do you think there's some aliens there or beings there?
I think there's something illuminated by it.
There.
What do you think is illuminated back there?
I don't know.
Is it like the John Lear, like soul catcher?
No, I don't believe in all that, but man.
So what, what, what do you think is illuminated on the backside of the moon?
I don't know, but, um, I have to leave that.
If you were to give a high level riddle or hint.
Um, I don't know.
I just think that the backside is nothing like the front side.
If you find photos of it.
If they're real, it doesn't look anything like the front side.
And from what I've seen, there is something behind it hidden back there.
And, and Tim seemed to think that it wasn't there by accident.
Just the mood.
Exactly what he told me.
It wasn't by accident.
Was it towed into place?
That was one of the things he was in towed into place.
Yeah.
That was one of the conversations I heard.
Wow.
Do you think, do you get the vibe that he has?
Some metaphysical worldview that is more concrete because the average person you
talk to them about metaphysics and if they speak in a self-assured way, they're
probably full of shit and they're either full of shit or they're really epistemically
humble and they're like, I don't know.
I take these things metaphorically and, you know, so it's like one or the other.
And then occasionally, occasionally, especially if you're a seeker, like, you
know, you are, I am.
You meet somebody and it's like, you have kind of a more concrete understanding of what's
going on out there.
Right.
Do you feel like he's one of those people?
He is a hundred percent that way.
You feel like that?
Yeah.
And you don't think he was sort of conning you in any way or?
No.
Well, I thought that some of the things he said flew in the face of what I believed then.
But now years later, you know, I thought it's changed on this thing.
And so some of the things he was telling me makes more sense today.
Do you think there's a native American connection?
A lot of people, you know, I've interviewed Mario Woods on my show who, uh, you know, is
native of native American descent and people say that, you know, if you have, yeah, that,
that, that ancestry, you might be able to get in touch with this stuff a little more
easily.
Other people say that about RH negative blood.
Do you think either of those things are true?
I think there's a possibility with the blood.
I'm not sure about that, but I do.
No.
I know that I was, uh, a book showed up to my house that, uh, was sent from some folks
in the government, CIA and said, read this.
And it was the miss and I, I can't remember the whole title, but it was the ancient mission
lore of the Cherokee and it was written by James Mooney in 1891.
That's when it was published in 1891 by James Mooney.
And the book talks about the Cherokee little people.
It talks about the thunder boys.
It talks about a missing time.
It talks about all sorts of stuff in this book.
And, um, that when they gave me that they were particularly interested if I had a native
American blood in my DNA.
And so I went and had all that done to ancestry and 23 and me come to find out.
I'm 99% Irish, British, Scottish, you know, so no native American there.
Have you ever seen a UFO in a hanger?
Nope.
You just seen it in the, in this base or on the ground.
Do you think that, uh, the kind of, you know, security establishment in the U S has UFOs in, in its possession, the reverse engineering now?
Well, they're big liars if they don't cause they've been successful.
Yeah.
I've been saying it for years.
They haven't really beaten that drum right now.
They are big liars.
Same, same, same story for 50, 70 years.
Now we have this, we saw that my friend saw it.
I saw a letter.
Here's another letter.
I saw, I saw, I saw.
That's all you hear, but you never see.
Yeah.
That's what's so strange.
Never.
Yeah.
It was very me.
I'm sharing it.
You know, I tell you there's orbs there and then we go out and we see them, but I'm not labeling it.
And do you feel like, cause I think on Sean Ryan's show, Diana Pasolka spoke about your experience almost as if you had been like messed with or something.
Do you feel like you've been messed with or manipulated in any way or.
No.
Um, I think the phenomenon has a way of doing things to trick you.
You know, you hear jocks fillet, right?
About the trickster.
Well, that's not a bad.
Bad thing.
I think it's like the adjustment Bureau, same thing.
If, if, if Jesse, if you, if you want to go this direction, it might, it might trick you to make you go in the opposite direction.
So it's kind of controlling your path.
So, um, that would be, yeah, I'm a few of that, but you don't feel like, um, the Intel world has tried to.
Shade your perception of things in any way.
I think they have.
Okay.
Yeah, they have from the beginning.
They, they tried to make me believe in fine saucers and little green men.
Really?
Yeah.
And I kept telling them, no, it wasn't like that.
Interesting.
It wasn't like that.
But that, so who, who was trying to kind of implant those ideas?
Uh, hundreds of people within the government.
I've met hundreds.
Really?
And they all go back to that, you know, it was, you know, here, you know, I got labeled.
Uh, a religious fanatic because I said it was spiritual.
I've been saying it was spiritual for 19 years.
And so they were really adamant about, Hey, like, let's spin this towards this, you know, kind of alien extraterrestrial thing.
Yeah.
Constantly alien, alien, alien.
What you're seeing is negative, bad.
Really?
Yeah.
That's pretty crazy.
That's not cool.
No, it's not cool.
So how do you explain that?
What's happening there?
Where you have.
These.
Spooky.
People coming into your life, telling you that what you saw was alien when you know it wasn't.
And then you have somebody like Jim semi van, who's very high up at the CIA seems to pro I assume knows a lot about a whole lot of national security things outside of the UFO issue.
But the UFO issue he's gone very deep on for decades.
Right.
And he's being kind of an honest actor and telling you, you know, you experience what you experienced.
Do you, do you think he was, you know, honest with you?
Yeah.
Jim.
Uh,
you know, I have a deep, uh, care for Jim and he does my family as well.
And we've shared a lot of stuff I know about his story and Debbie's his wife.
And, um,
so you think they're factions?
Like, how do you make sense of the fact that you have one half of Intel world spinning, you're attempting to spin your story and like kind of manipulate you.
And then you have another half that just seems kind of like good hearted.
Well, it's kind of, it's kind of.
It's kind of like this.
There's a group of lower level guys that have a mission to do, um, disinformation, push a certain narrative, but you know, the people I'm meeting are heads of their departments, not necessarily this low level guy.
I'm talking the head of the director of operations like Jim was at the CIA.
He was James Bond.
That's who he was or director of operations.
Yeah.
Well, Jim was.
What is that like ranking of the.
So he ran the whole Northern hemisphere.
Well, everybody answered to him.
Yeah.
That's who he is.
Very powerful guy and his friends.
I've met a lot of them from, you know, the deputy director.
And, and when you talk to these guys in private, they pick your brain and you start learning more that, um, they're learning.
They want to know that that's, that's what I've come to the conclusion of, you know, everybody's like, oh, it's a psyop.
And they're trying.
To, you know, manipulate, blah, blah, blah, blah, blah.
And I, I've not been probably in as many of these rooms as you have, but I've been in some of them.
I'm sure.
And I'm like, they're, they're like, we're fans and we're, they're like trying to piece stuff together through, I used to be so afraid I would do certain interviews.
I'd break certain stories and I'd be like, oh, I got too close to the truth.
They're going to, they're going to come after me.
And then now I'm like, oh, they're probably learning alongside me and like using, you know, the stuff I'm.
Learning.
And through open-source research, like for their own shit or whatever.
Well, for the most part, they're, they're, um, they truly are people like us and they want to know, but there's a program of guys that's involved in the UFO world, keeping that going.
But the, do you think, is there some, cause you met, you opened the book talking about John Alexander, right?
John Alexander also seems to show when people experience paranormal things like the Hutchinson effect.
You know, John Hutchinson, California, sort of, you know, metallic equipment seems to hover in like, you know, malfunction around him.
It seems to have like all these electromagnetic anomalies emitting from his body.
Um, you, you know, other cases, John Alexander will kind of consistently show up.
Um, I think he's briefed on that.
Like, I think he knew about Rendlesham before anybody else.
Yeah, he did a hundred percent.
John is what's his deal.
John has been.
And let's just say he's probably the number one researcher in the paranormal world for the U S government has been for many, many years.
Yeah.
His wife is works, study and religion as a part of this.
And he's been to 90, 92 countries doing, um, research and to everything from churches to ceremonies in Mongolia, the reindeer herders, you know, the reindeer monk.
He, they.
I rode horses a hundred miles.
And do you think he has a pure agenda or do you think that he has an agenda to find the truth?
And, but he does, he does often he'll see these things and then he'll kind of semi debunk them.
And I don't think he did in your case, but I think in other, like, uh, you know, the Hutchinson thing, he'll show up and he'll be like, well, it kind of works at sometimes, but it's, you know, like if you read his writing, it's often like.
It's not as.
Magical as you think, sort of like, you kind of like, you know,
but John's more in line of, um, he don't look at the physical thing as being the truth of it, or the alien thing as being the truth of it.
He doesn't see it that way.
He's more about, it's more, that's too easy.
It's far more complex than that.
This thing does it, for example.
Hmm.
In the 1800s, 1700s, go back and read all the reports on UFOs, people were seeing, I read a story of, uh, a sailing ship with glowing sails flying over London and an anchor comes out and snags a chimney and breaks the top off of a chimney, a boat, a flying boat.
Right.
So here's these flying ships, uh, sky ships, they call them for many, many years.
In fact, the first report.
Yeah.
I've heard of in America was Aurora, Texas.
It was a sky ship that crashed into the wind tower.
Right.
1897.
And they buried an alien there.
You know where they buried him?
Where?
In my family, right beside my family cemetery.
Really?
Yeah.
That's weird.
That is really trippy.
Masonic cemetery.
What?
Yeah.
So do you, do you have other trippy things like that in your family history?
Quite a bit of stuff.
Tim was the one that started that research with me.
Yeah.
Way back in Diana.
So Tim is sort of an error in some ways to John Alexander, where he's also doing a lot
of this sort of paranormal research.
Yeah.
But what's so interesting to me is he's has a functional job at NASA too.
Well, that's part of his job.
Wow.
Do you think that space, like our space travel program is somehow related to
studying these paranormal things?
Yeah.
How do you think it's related?
Well, you heard him talk about it when you were speaking about, uh, creating, investing in a rocket company, it's up to them, right?
I don't know.
You know, I, I know the history of rocketry, you know, and I know Jack Parsons thought he was in touch with, you know, other beings and literally saw like, uh, w what you could describe as a Nordic alien woman, you know, while he was testing rockets, you know, in California, uh, in the Mojave desert.
I know that.
Um, Tsiolovsky, the Russian equivalent thought he was in touch with angelic beings.
Herman Oberth, you know, the, the father of the German rocket, rocket program, all of them thought that.
Thought they were in angels.
Yeah.
So, but then I also know Elon Musk, you know, kind of dismisses the whole alien thing and.
Well, Hal Paulymeier told me, and, uh, before I tell you that we'll get back to the flying ships.
Right.
In 1947, Kenneth Arnold sees, uh, these little Chevron.
Flying about, and they were kind of moving freely and, you know, half a dozen of them.
And the reporter says, well, how did they move, Kenneth?
And he said, well, if you took a saucer out of the cupboard and you threw it and it skipped on the water, he said, that's the way they look.
Well, the reporter said, ah, Kenneth Arnold sees flying saucers, right?
So it goes out on the news.
AP wire now billion plus people has it implanted in their brain.
Right.
50 years.
What did they see?
Saucers.
Flying saucers.
Where'd they go?
Yeah.
Where are they?
Right.
Then comes a triangle in the 80s or 90s.
All of a sudden, everybody's seeing triangles.
Yes.
Then I come along in 07.
These big balls of fire come.
Mifflin's like, well, what were they?
I said, I don't know.
They wasn't flying saucers.
They were, they were light.
They were like orbs.
And so that kind of hung it.
And from 2000, last night.
10 years, it's been orbs.
So our perception of something celestial and in some almost like other world plate to platonic
realm that we can't understand or comprehend is being sort of shaded by basically media
by like our, the memes that we have in our, in our head.
Right.
That's fascinating.
And to anybody, is this such a cool conversation to have with you?
Because I think some people throw around the term like psyop w like with you and
stuff.
And I'm like, the fact that you're saying all this stuff is like, so opposite, the opposite
of like somebody who's dogmatically like, you know, proposing the kind of extra terrestrial
hypothesis.
It's like, you're basically saying like, we're in some limited, you know, epistemological
realm or whatever.
And we're seeing something that's unexplained.
And that's a humble claim.
I don't think that I'm not here to label it.
Cause I would be lying if I told you, I knew.
Yeah.
All I can tell you is 19 years of patterns.
I can tell you that I get a lot of people to call me that want to tell me their story.
I've covered my book empowers these people.
And I get this little lady calls me one night and it's just for an example.
And she's like, um, she said, I saw this ball of light go by my kitchen window.
Can, um, and I hear, she said this, she said, she's 87.
She said, I hear tell you're the person that would know about these things.
I said, well, yeah, um, I try to help you, you know, so tell me what happened.
She said, I was washing dishes and it came up to the window and it scared me and it went
away.
I said, well, what was going on with you right then?
She saw I was washing dishes.
I said, no, what was your life like?
And soon as she said it, I knew it's the same story for 19 years over and over and over
and over a thousand.
Times is my husband died the week before.
And it's always the same.
People start seeing this stuff.
I had a near death.
Um, uh, my daughter died, my mom died, my son died or something horrible.
I think it's always that way.
It's almost like, um, I think about it, them showing up at nuclear sites,
which they seem to show up at.
And if there was some.
Archimedes lever point.
Point of most leverage to shift timelines on like a globe, global scale, it would be
there.
And then in somebody's life, maybe you'd show up at peak highs and peak lows and sort
of the, the, you know, peaks in the valleys or something.
And I wonder if that's the case.
I wonder if, well, is that anecdotally your case?
I mean, do you think people even in, in like kind of peak states also see them?
Cause that's, that's been my anecdotal understanding.
Yeah, I think it's possible.
Right.
But I do know that the majority of the people witnessing this now is different
because it is coming, it's revealing itself and there's no stopping that.
It's gonna reveal itself completely.
Uh, and, and it's what it's doing is cracking people's consciousness.
Just a little bit makes you think, you know, it may not convert that person,
but it, it, they're like, oh my God, there is something out there.
So it's.
It's expanding our consciousness.
Do you think other people think that you are the Messiah?
I've been asked to, yeah, but I don't see that.
I'm just a poor guy that had, uh, has had a hard time.
Yeah.
And, uh, it's not been easy.
It's been a burden more than anything.
And I'm just a messenger.
I know that I can share this with people and after I do, then it's yours.
You can, you can.
Connect with it from then.
So it's not like something that I have, it's something that everybody has the right to.
Mm.
Do you feel like you, you have an understanding of metaphysics that's
deeper than the average person's like, is it, is there some sort of thing that
you can relay about how the world works?
No, I'm still trying to pick her that, but, um, and I'm not in a shell.
I know that we're not in control.
Hmm.
That our thoughts are completely understood by something above us
that knows everything about you.
It knows your heart.
It knows your intentions and it will guide you, or it will tear you
down if you're going the wrong way.
That's the trickster part of it.
But is that bad?
You know, it's intended for you to marry this person, not that one.
It might do what it takes to get you to meet this person.
Yeah.
Mm.
So fascinating.
Yeah.
And it's your job to be receptive and to kind of ride the ride the wave
or listen to the synchronicities, or yeah.
That's what I do.
I listened to his synchronicities, but my job is to share a truth that,
uh, everyone's been told is not real.
And, uh, uh, I caught so much problem from the community in 2007, when this happened,
half my family, 2 3rds of my family.
in my family I quit speaking to, my own cousins and family.
And it was because they wouldn't believe me
or I was being accused of messing with the devil, right?
And so they actively got hard on me
and tried to remove my children from me.
That was early on, right after it happened.
And so I kind of took offense to everyone
and I made a vow then I'm gonna prove them all wrong.
I'm gonna prove the world wrong.
That's what I said.
I made that and I worked on it pretty hard
for 19 years of revealing something
that nobody says is real.
And what that is, I can't tell you with 100% certainty,
but I can tell you in 19 years of patterns
and never no harm to me or anyone else
that has experienced this.
And I've shared it with thousands of people.
Do you think the idea of disclosure
is kind of a misnomer?
Mm-hmm.
It's the idea that the government can disclose
some sort of like metaphysical truth
that they have this asymmetric understanding of.
Yeah, I think we're in post-disclosure.
Disclosure is not an announcement.
They're never gonna give you the secrets.
You know, if they have a machine, you're not gonna see it.
And I wouldn't want them to
because somebody else could get ahold of it
and it could be terrible, right?
So it's national security.
They're never gonna give you that.
So they're just gonna give a talk all the time.
We have, we've seen, we have.
Disclosure is a one person at the time awakening.
Suddenly you see it's real.
You saw an orb, oh my God, what was it?
I don't know what it was, but it wasn't an airplane.
And it stopped and it came up to me
and it flashed me and it went away.
Well, that absolutely changes everybody's world paradigm.
It just completely changes it and sets you on a different,
a different course then.
So awakening or disclosure is for those,
there's a lot of people that's already, that knows.
And so I don't think the government's gonna
ever announce anything.
They're just gonna keep telling you we have this
and we saw that and make people get curious
and start investigating.
What do you think people's relationship
should be to your story?
Because on the one hand you were cured of Crohn's disease.
And I know you've had some other physical challenges
since then, but that's a really major thing
that kind of you were alleviated by
and presumably linked to this kind of amazing event
in January of 2007.
Do you think people can experience spontaneous healings
and should they go for that?
Or should they go for the like incremental
kind of more deliberate thing?
Like is that, it feels like catching lightning in a bottle.
Yeah.
And how can that happen in a repeatable way
unless Jesus is real or something and can heal us?
Well, I said earlier,
maybe we have our own power to heal ourselves.
We just don't know it.
Do you feel like you healed yourself in that instance?
Or they healed you?
No, I think they healed me.
And I think that they will heal or they can.
They can heal you.
I've seen it too many times.
I've seen it happen in Australia over the phone.
Long distance, that's it.
And magic happens at that point.
And I don't claim that as me doing it.
I'm just the mediator guy.
I just present our picture to the heavens.
Yeah.
So, you know, it's all thought and intention.
Our thoughts are very powerful and our intentions.
I know they are.
Yeah, they really are.
Right.
And they, everything was once a thought.
And I think thoughts have a much greater effect
on reality than just thought converts to action,
which produces this mechanical sort of, you know,
pinball machine, which ends up doing a thing.
There's clearly something else going on
that I think will be proven out by science.
I think you're right there.
Yeah.
Do you think that there's a space program
involving consciousness that's deeper than,
because you think about, you know,
there's this, you know, 17th century Swedish mystic,
Emanuel Swedenborg.
And he described, you know, going up into the cosmos
and seeing all these, you know, stars and planets,
and you've had out of body experiences
and you've been to the Monroe Institute.
Right.
If I was forming some, you know, sleeper cell space program
that might be able to traverse farther
than just NASA nuts and bolts craft,
if you believe remote viewing is a real modality,
you have to believe some sort of astral space travel
is also real.
It is real.
So do you think there's some sort of vital program
in the government that involves
consciousness-based space travel?
I think they've attempted that and still are trying to.
They have to have.
Yeah, yeah.
And you even watch Carl Sagan's Contact
and it's like, that's kind of what you're touching on.
Yeah, exactly.
You know?
Or you, you know, Christopher Nolan,
who you read, you watch Interstellar
and then you read the physics of Interstellar by Kip Thorne.
And it's like, if anybody was kind of dripped some, you know,
if anybody was kind of dripped some, you know,
if anybody was kind of dripped some interesting info,
it probably would have been, you know, Nolan.
Right.
And it's just so fast.
It's like this fifth dimensional space that, you know,
where you can travel kind of maybe between timelines.
And then when you die, you're able to, you know,
traverse that.
And it's sort of hard to talk about a lot of these things,
but.
That's a big one.
You know, I believe when we die,
that based on the photo evidence I have,
you may have, you know,
some of that that I shared with Anna, right?
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
In fact, it's going to come out on our pod
where she shows some really interesting photos.
Well, you see photos with people in them
or children or animals.
Where did I get that?
How did I get those?
And this was right after the lady came.
And at that time I didn't have a video camera.
I had a cell phone with the flip phone, right?
But I went out and bought a little pocket camera,
a little Instamatic.
And I started taking just every night.
I wasn't able to get anything before,
but from that point forward, I did.
And it's like my dog died.
I wrote about this in the book.
I was with Tim at Cape Canaveral for a week.
And some guys from the NRO and we were meeting
and at a launch and had been there all week.
And it was Saturday.
Launch finally went off Saturday, delayed all week.
My wife knew I was coming home at Sunday morning
or Sunday night.
I was going to leave after the launch, Saturday night,
get up Sunday morning, drive home.
So at four o'clock it was over.
I said, Tim, I'm going to Fayetteville.
So I got my car and I took off.
Didn't tell anybody, drove all night long, all night.
Pulled over to rest areas, 13 hours, right?
From my house there, pulled over and took a nap.
8.30 Sunday morning, I drove in the yard.
When I drove in the yard,
I knew immediately that my Labrador was dead.
I knew it.
I can't tell you how I knew it, but I knew it.
Just came right into my mind.
I saw it all.
I felt it.
My kids and family had buried her in the backyard
three days before.
Never told me because they didn't want me upset, right?
It was like my child, this 90 pound Labrador,
female named Nellie.
I opened the front door and walked in.
My wife's asleep at the front door in the living room
on the couch, house full of kids.
They'd been up all weekend.
They had invited all their friends.
So mom kind of would stay near the front
where all the bedrooms were.
Our little girl, she was the only girl, right?
So mom's doing, she's doing her patrol
to keep any boys away from her.
That's what moms do.
So I walked in the door and I opened it.
She looks up at me.
I said, what happened to my dog?
And her eyes got big.
And she said, oh my God, how did you know?
I said, well, I felt her.
She said, well, she ran out on the road
and got run over by a car.
And we buried her in the backyard.
So I took, and I thought about it all day.
And that night I thought, she don't know she's dead.
That's how I knew it.
It was when I turned off the road right where she was killed.
It just kind of felt her and saw her in my thoughts.
So I took a little white candle.
I went out to her grave and I lit it.
And I told her, I said, I'll be with you again.
Just go to the light.
And she comes up out of her grave
and a little ball of light.
And I took that picture and that's how I got that.
Wow, that's amazing.
And you should have a copy of it.
I would love to see that.
Yeah, we could put that up.
So what does that tell you?
You know, what does that tell you?
And I've got people, lots of people and children.
In fact, I have a child, my wife and I lost a child.
We have four, but we lost.
A child and I was out thinking about him
and this lonely orb, here it comes.
And I took a picture of it and there was a child.
Yeah.
In the orb.
In the orb and this is my screenshot.
Wow.
I'm gonna show you.
Oh my God, that's a real photo.
That's a photo of a child and it was a ball of light.
That's a real photo.
Yeah.
That is amazing.
So what does that tell you?
I believe that when, I think that we're in a simulation
or we're in this avatar that we experience time
because of our body, but beyond the body, there is no time.
And I think when we die that we go back
to that eternal place, which is in church,
they tell you it's somewhere way far away,
but I think it's just around us.
Yeah.
Well, there's.
Time is created by the mind and the body
and time is the most used noun in the English language,
but nobody knows how to define it without respect
to the movement of bodies or things.
It's always something defined relative to something else.
So if you're doing that over and over again,
then it has to be this soup that you're swimming in
where you can't get out of it.
Exactly.
You're like in water and you don't,
it's like this David Foster Wallace speech
where he goes, this is water, you know, and it's like,
you're, you're, you're a fish in water.
You have no idea what you're in.
We're in this stream of time.
There's no way out of it.
There's no way to talk about it.
And really, you know.
There's no words for it.
That photo is amazing.
Yeah.
Can we show this to like a NASA photo instrumentation person?
Yeah, I don't care.
A lot of them have already seen it.
Okay.
I tell you, I was just to tell you how it is with NASA.
I was at, I was in a Capitol Hill club.
Mm-hmm.
When the, when the, when the hearing,
the recent hearing that happened, right?
Yeah.
And, and in fact, it was Anna Brady
and a bunch of those friends of hers
and without using names.
And we were having hors d'oeuvres with,
with Eric Burleson and Anna Luna, right?
And afterwards we went out and did a sky watch
on the, the Library of Congress, right?
We were up on the platform.
And suddenly a swerve appears and for 45 minutes
it did figure eights over the Capitol and the White House.
So, and Burleson saw it.
No, Burleson wasn't there.
He had gone home, but Anna was there.
Anna was there.
And a whole group of other people,
Eric Zydak from PG&E Power.
Donna Roberts from the International Space Station.
She was standing next to me.
Others, I can't say their name,
but they've come out publicly, this group.
Oh, excuse me, Tracy McGill.
She's an analyst for the DOA, DOD, I think.
Whoa.
Fascinating.
So they all got to experience it.
While we were having dinner,
you were talking about NASA people.
This guy walks up and he's, he gives me a big hug.
He said, Chris, I'm a huge fan.
And he introduced me to his son.
We'd never met, right?
But he was one of the highest ranking guys at NASA.
He walks up and hugs me.
And he says, I'm a huge fan of yours.
NASA.
Yeah.
So why is NASA publicly?
It's their policy.
They're gaslighting the public.
The people there, the people there are just like me and you.
It's so funny.
Cause it's like, you see them publicly
and it's like, they're doing this thing on three eye Atlas.
And it's like, the photo is the resolution of,
it's like, you're looking at a lamp post.
Yeah, right.
You know, on, it's like a street light or something.
Yeah.
It's horrible.
And the amateur astronomers are getting better stuff.
Exactly.
And then privately, they're going to you saying,
we're, we're big fans.
Yeah.
So interesting.
Isn't that crazy?
It is crazy.
That's a little frustrating.
It's like, can you close, can you split the,
close the gap a little bit between your public
and your private, you know, perception?
One thing Hal told me, Hal Poppenmeier.
We were, we loved him.
My children loved Hal because he became, you know,
my dad died in 2013.
And he was, you know, my dad died in 2013.
And he, Hal came in 2008.
And.
You just showed up at your door, right?
Yeah.
Knocked on the door in 2008.
He's a massive guy showing up at your door.
And so he'd come three or four times a year
and stay a week at the time.
And his biggest thing was my children.
He would, they would bring school friends over
and he'd have a big, you know, he loved kids.
So he'd pull out Mastodon teeth and Tektites.
And it was just a big party of science.
And he loved that.
But.
Hal told me he died in 2019.
He died in 2019.
He was coming to our house for Thanksgiving, he and Katie,
and he fell and hit his head and went in a coma
and never woke up.
Right?
But he told me right before he died, he said,
Chris, I want to tell you one thing.
He said, I've wondered for many years.
He said, what this phenomenon is.
Oh, I know all about it.
He said, you know, I've seen it all.
He said, I don't even know it.
He said, but we've always been on the fence of what it is we're dealing with.
But he said, when I know now, to me it's, he believed it was angelic.
They were always on the fence of what it is.
But he observed it with me a lot and saw its nature and how it would react to certain words and certain prayer.
And was he religious?
Well, he wasn't religious at all, but he was, toward the end of his life, he became very open in prayer and stuff.
That'll make you religious.
Tim Taylor had a conversion right at the Vatican where he converted to Catholicism.
Yeah, exactly.
It's fascinating.
So that's where the stink takes you.
It takes you down that path if you interact with it, it will.
There's an apocryphal quote that's often attributed to Warden of Heisenberg.
And?
You know, he's this amazing physicist, but he was also in charge of the German nuclear program under the Nazis.
But also a much deeper philosophical guy, and he regretted his kind of role in that stuff.
And he says, the first sip of the bottle, you know, of science makes you an atheist.
But when you get to the bottom, you find God at the bottom.
Right.
That's where Hal was at the end.
Yeah.
That's what it sounds like.
Yeah, exactly what it was.
Yeah.
That photo you showed me with the child in the orb, that looks exactly like in 2001 Space Odyssey, at the end of the movie, where Bowman, he's, you know, going up on the ship, and then he ends up, I don't know what happens, but there's this, it's this weird, bizarre, surreal scene.
And you see the monolith, and then all of a sudden it cuts to this baby hovering.
Hovering over the earth in this, like, orb capsule thing.
Yeah, crazy, right.
And I watched, I remember watching that.
It's one of those things where I'm like, I am too unenlightened and dumb to know what this means.
Right.
But I know it means something.
And that's what a lot of the UFO topic is.
It's like the sound of the one hand clapping, the Zen koan, you're like, and it just makes you want to go further.
And you're like, you see something, you're like, you don't quite know what it means, but you're like, that, there's something about that.
They're saying this.
And if anybody knew kind of, you know, some deeper truths about reality, like, I do think Arthur C. Clarke, Stanley Kubrick, guys like that were tapped into something deeper.
And so that photo tripped me out because I'm like, what did, what did they know?
And, you know, is that photo, you know, somehow lining up with what they knew?
I think they probably knew a lot more than they had to.
And the government knows a lot more, but this, everybody that see anybody in the ranks wants to see this stuff.
They want to know.
They want to know about it.
Yeah.
I believe it.
Who wouldn't?
Yeah.
Does the stuff, you know, about the dark side of the moon point towards sort of a simulated world?
Yeah, it does.
Yeah.
Well, that, then you get into these things around, like, why, why can't we have disclosure?
You can't say that official, if you're in some like official government position, you can't, you cannot say like, I would, I want as much disclosure as, as humanly possible, but like if you're Trump, yeah, that might be tough.
That might be.
That might be a tough one.
Exactly.
You go up there on the podium, you go, we're in a simulated universe.
Yeah, right.
You're, you're, you're, uh, everything is, you're in a karmic whirlpool where you get stuck.
You experience the same thing over and over again, but with a different veneer.
Time is actually an illusion.
Yeah.
And that veneer is just the changing of memes that are implanted in your head by some alien that, like, if you started to go deeper into that, where does that lead?
Where does that lead?
That leads to a very, you know.
And I, I think we might be headed there anyways.
I don't think we need authority figures necessarily to say these things.
I think we're going to, I think what's going to happen is that basically the way I see this is consciousness is just one big unified field, right?
It's all one.
And everything that exists is in that one from the ghosts to the aliens or to the angels and to us.
And I think we're in the process of rolling humanity's role.
We're rolling into that next dimension.
In other words, it'll be a world of, um, where we all in it, where we see it more.
And it's part of our reality is shifting.
And when it's fascinating, it's so interesting.
It's so fun to talk to you because I think a lot of people have said, oh, like, it's like you're too open minded or something is the, you know, the, the critique or something.
And I have a lot of critiques hurled at me.
So don't take that personally.
But, uh.
I think so.
I think if you believe in the parapsychology stuff, which I do, that there's some sort of mind matter connection.
Absolutely.
Then I think there's a correlation between openness and your effect on the material world or like your, what you perceive as well.
Right.
And so I think inherently there will be at times errors made due to that openness because you're sifting in this area.
That is so uncharted.
Exactly.
But you're also going to like, you know, come upon like really core deep truths and I don't know if you can have one without the other.
And so, you know what I mean?
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
Like, like, you know, I'm sure I've explored all sorts of like crazy stuff, but, but in reality, I think it, you know, my, I think my worldview is actually sometimes crazier than I can even communicate via the show.
Yeah.
And it's really about catching people up.
You know, epistemically and like taking people through this, like rigorous, like, well, let's start with the foundation.
Like that photo is real.
It's been verified.
You know, like you need to do that because we're in this materialist reductionist scientific paradigm.
Right.
Um, but, and, and, and you'll make a lot of, you know, errors along the way, but yeah, it's this really kind of hard thing because you, you make one error and you get these kind of debunker skeptic types and they'll just hang on that one error.
Yeah.
For the whole, and it's like, they're seeing what they want to see.
Well, the thing people give these debunkers and skeptics too much power.
Yeah.
Oh boy.
I don't even pay them attention.
Yeah.
To me, they're just uninformed.
Well, I think the thing that deflates them too is like, I'll admit, like, I've gotten a whole ton of stuff wrong.
Like, and I hope, I hope you would admit that too.
Yeah, I have.
I changed, you know, we learned.
Yeah, that's right.
Right.
Yeah.
And as long as you can adapt with.
Right.
New information that comes in, you know, then this is all it's, it's, it's really new territory.
So.
Oh, there's, there's no book.
There's no, there's no vocabulary for this.
None.
It's all invisible and we have to create a vocabulary for it and we've got to put a story to it, right?
As humans do that.
So you're constantly adjusting that as you go and pulling all the information together
and.
Yeah.
down the road you think, well, what you thought before
is not correct, you know, so it could be different.
So I leave an open mind to it.
I try not to label it, but I will go so far as to say
that it's been benevolent and I've seen healings from it
and I know how it answers when I say certain words.
It gets excited.
Which words?
The lady.
Really?
That's all you gotta say.
The lady.
Interesting.
Yep.
When you start talking about her, and I can do this,
I can take a group of people outside at night,
I've done it over and over and over,
take a mic if we got a big enough group.
It's gotten pretty simple because,
and I shouldn't say it's simple, it's complex,
but still it's happened so much that it's pretty crazy.
Do you think there are pockets,
air pockets of consensus reality
and what I mean by that is like,
do you think, you know the Mandela effect?
Yeah.
So this idea that a lot of people in the 90s
thought that Mandela died in prison,
which he obviously didn't, you know?
Do you think that reality might work more like that
than we think?
And so certain mystical experiences happen
and the people with eyes to see and ears to hear
experience it and then other people walk away
and they're like, yeah, I don't know, it was a thing,
it happened or whatever, or they like,
we'll superimpose some prosaic explanation upon the thing.
And reality itself is far more fractured, malleable,
and in the eye of the beholder than what it is.
Yeah, and it's changing.
It's constantly changing like the Mandela effect
you talked about.
One thing that surprised me is my wife
and I've been married 43 years, right?
So our honeymoon was in New York City.
We'd never been there, either one of us.
We had a plan.
We wanted to see the train station,
Grand Central Station, right?
So we go to Grand Central Station
and we get photos and videos and we took a helicopter ride
and we did all kind of things to experience New York.
And so I'm looking at my old photos
of Grand Central Station, right?
Well, Google it now.
It's not called that, it's called Grand Central Terminal
and it says it's never been called that.
But yet I got photos of Grand Central Station.
Yeah.
Written on the thing.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
But you see it now, it says Grand Central Terminal.
What's that about?
Well, you know, the Flintstones,
the Berenstys, Berenstein Bears,
all these things where people swear
that, you know, it was like one way
and then you look at the record
and it actually looks like there's another way.
Yeah.
And, you know, it is this really amazing phenomena.
And then you get into deeper studies,
like there's this neuroscience.
I mean, you know, there's a scientist, Wilder Penfield,
and you realize that there is no way of distinguishing
between false memories and true memories.
And he shows this with the ability
to implant false memories into mice and stuff.
And then you get, if there are these beings
and any thoughts can be sort of implanted,
you get into really weird ontological territory
where the past, and even Schrodinger himself would say,
a particle is measured in the present,
you know, it might change its past.
Right.
And you get into retrocausality in quantum mechanics.
There's obviously spooky action at a distance,
but there's also spooky action across time.
Right.
It seems like if you have two entangled photons
and two double slit experiments run with those,
you know, entangled photons,
seems like photon B that you're doing the experiment
with two days in the future,
if you measure that and you don't measure the first one,
the measurement of the one in the future
is affecting the one of the measurement in the past.
Exactly.
There's a great book called Biocentrism,
that this guy Robert Lanza writes about this stuff.
So you get into really trippy territory
where the past becomes,
the present is this constricted present,
but it's like an hourglass where you have probable futures
and probable pasts.
Right.
And the present is this measurement sensor
that is single line of code updating the past
and maybe updating the future at the same time.
Right.
And it's this very strange sort of model,
but there's no real way to argue against that
other than physical artifacts.
So if you have physical artifacts around an event happening,
you can argue, say this is evidence
that this happened this way or this happened another way.
If you have conflicting physical artifacts
where you don't have physical artifacts,
it's totally one word against the other word
or you can get into like numbers of people
who believe one thing
or numbers of people that believe another thing.
But we have no idea how reality works.
We have no idea.
We have a very limited, we are measurement sensors.
And so this idea that science
is some ontological statement of truth,
like no, it's the map, it's not the territory.
Exactly.
It's just we see very limited scopes of reality.
Right.
And time is the weirdest thing of all.
Yeah, that has messed with me
ever since I went there and saw that.
And now everything I dig up,
it says it was never called that.
Yeah, Grand Central, yeah.
But the sign was on the wall.
It's funny, as you said Grand Central Station,
I was like, oh, of course, Grand Central Station.
Go Google it now though, it's not that.
Grand Central Terminal, it doesn't even sound as good.
Yeah, it's always been named that according to this.
Yeah.
So I don't know what that means,
but it was really, it really opened my eyes
to how weird this world we live in really is.
How do you juggle, you know,
a lot of these concepts might seem crazy
to the average person.
How do you juggle just facing, you know,
relationships, issues, things in your own life
versus these kind of deeper celestial metaphysical truths?
Those two things seem kind of hard to juggle.
I was talking to a friend yesterday
and he has all these teachers, you know,
kind of in the Eastern tradition.
He's kind of his own mystic in a sense.
And I think I can say this actually,
his name is Duncan Trussell.
And he's, you know, I actually just met him.
He's an amazing comedian, but I felt a kinship with him.
And he talked, he said, he said, he said, I don't know,
he said his teachers all said that,
and these are like Eastern, you know,
kind of Buddhists say that, you know,
they know that the celestial realm exists,
but they ignore it because what we need to do
is here on earth, we have these kind of karmic path
laid out in front of you.
So I'm sure a lot of people have this sort of escapist
orientation towards this subject where they say,
oh, well, take me up on the craft, you know?
So how do you reconcile those two things?
I don't, I mean, it's like, it's just,
it's mind-bending, the whole thing.
I'm still grappling with that, you know, to this very day.
And I focus on, right now, my main focus
is on the Rosetta Stone.
Really?
Why is your focus on the Rosetta Stone?
Because I believe that I can find, I think I can get there.
I think, I know it's talking.
I know it is.
I know it's talking multiple ways,
not just telepathically,
because that's hard to prove or explain,
but I'm sure it's talking through frequency,
through the light, pulses of light,
with the right sensors,
and even some sort of Morse code or something.
Multiple ways it's trying to communicate.
I've seen it, I know it,
and I think one day we'll get there.
You think the Rosetta Stone is trying to communicate?
I think the Phenomenon is trying to talk to us,
and to find that Rosetta Stone, you know,
that's just the language.
I want to find the language of this.
Of the beings.
Yeah, and it's putting it out right now, it's talking.
We just got to study it, and I'm working on a way to do that.
Do you think their language is discoveries?
Like the discoveries we make?
Yeah.
What do you think the language is?
Do you think it's a literal symbols and hieroglyphics?
Because people say on the crafts that, you know,
they see these sort of hieroglyphics.
Yeah.
I've heard biblical texts and all on them too.
And you think we'll be able to decode this?
I think we can get actual real-time communication
through the light and through sensors.
If we can gather enough data.
How would we do this?
Put it in a quantum AI computer.
Mm.
And there's two of them that I could probably get access to.
So you're working on this?
I'm working on it, yeah.
Have you decoded anything yet?
Well, we're working on it.
That's all I can say.
Well, it sounds like you have decoded a little thing or two.
Some, some, yeah.
Anything you can give us?
Enough to get me going full-time.
I'm saying anything you can give us as far as,
hints as to what you've decoded.
Well, just that I know it's there.
And I think we'll be able to do that.
Yeah. And I think we'll be able to do that.
And I think we'll get there
in the next four or five years, maybe.
Maybe longer.
Do you think there's something special
about the pyramids that we'll learn soon or something?
Because, I mean, one of your experiences
was around the pyramids.
Obviously, Hathor, Egyptian goddess.
Well, I'm hearing that next year
that something might be revealed from there.
What will it be?
Well, without getting ahead of what I was told this week,
I've been invited to go down there.
And be involved in something
that is going to release something that was hidden.
Interesting.
And what?
Something under the pyramids?
Possibly.
Like a little energy grid thing?
They didn't tell me that.
Okay.
They just invited me to be a part.
And the Egyptian antiquities authorities are part of it.
Fascinating.
Well, I just interviewed the guy
that did the synthetic aperture radar Doppler tomography scans.
Of the structure under the Khafre chamber of the Giza pyramid.
I can't say that's what it is.
I can just say I got a call from the right people
that wants me to be a part next year.
Well, that's exciting.
Yeah.
Very interesting.
So I think something's coming from there
that's gonna be real interesting.
Wow.
Like changing, thought changing.
Yeah.
Danny Jones, it was funny.
Danny Jones, I think, came into your interview with him,
maybe a little skeptical, but then he said,
he saw an orb with you outside of a diner or something.
Well, he called me.
He's like, I want you on my show.
I'm like, Danny, I'd love to be on your show,
but you gotta do something for me.
I'm gonna come a day or two early
and I'm gonna make you a believer, not a skeptic.
Because our interview will go differently
if you're a believer.
And he said, okay, okay.
So we flew down, my daughter and I and my wife,
and we had dinner there in Clearwater.
Went over to Indian Rocks Beach out on the beach
and he had his assistant with him with a camera.
And I said, well, let's watch out of the ocean
because I can get it, it appears up out of the ocean
when I ask it.
It's just like out of the sky, it comes up out of the sea.
And suddenly here it came, two of them.
Wow.
And he filmed it, we all filmed it.
Was he freaking out?
Yeah.
Wow.
We did that last week in California.
Yeah.
With some pretty amazing people.
Wow.
He also, Danny said he,
I think he cut a small part of your interview
where you talked about a neuralyzer,
like some like machine that erased your memory
after seeing something.
Yeah, I had to not talk about that.
You're not supposed to talk about that.
But there is something like that that you experienced?
I saw the patterns on it.
Really?
Yeah.
So, I mean, that's freaky if the government
has something that can do that.
Let's just say they can transmit chemicals
through radio waves.
Do you think they can transmit thoughts
through radio waves?
Yeah.
That's kind of creepy.
Well, then I get into all sorts of weird territory.
Like what is the whole UFO phenomenon?
Some paranormal plague from the thought transmission?
What if you were to see this alien appeared right here
and you saw it and you weren't supposed to?
What if it can shoot you with something
that would erase your thoughts?
You never remember.
So, you think the aliens can do that?
Or the beings can do that?
You do.
Why are you high conviction in that?
Seems like something where inherently if they can erase.
Well, I kind of learned some stuff on that
and I saw the patterns on it.
Well.
Yeah.
And you think they're real patterns?
Well, it was the US Patent Office talking about it.
Damn.
It's kind of crazy.
It's been hidden away.
I don't think it's not real.
It was stuffed away somewhere.
Yeah.
Dangerous technology.
Mm.
So, they could shoot you with a chemical,
drugs or anything from a hundred yards.
Think about that.
A few people have come on my show saying things like that.
I just, I never know what to make of it.
Cause I'm like, it's just, I don't know.
Just trust me.
I don't want that to not be true.
Where it came from was from our original conversations.
Mm.
So, with like Hal Poppenmeier?
Or with Tim Taylor?
Yeah.
Okay.
Very interesting. Yeah.
Well, I can tell you the world is a weird place.
I mean, just the fact that you went to Zanesville, Ohio,
did you learn anything else about Townsend Brown
while you were out there?
I never knew who he was until I got to Zanesville with Tim
and then he began to unfold who he was
and how he was working with his daughter
to finish a book about her father.
And I learned the whole story as much as he would tell me.
About his having visitors come and land.
Did Tim Taylor believe that Townsend Brown
made real anti-gravity breakthroughs as a scientist?
I can't tell you that he believed that or not,
but he felt it strong enough that he was, yeah.
I think he, I'm speculating.
Sure.
Yeah.
Have you heard other stories of experiencers
being shown a piece of metal and basically evaluated to,
you know, to see how they reacted?
To see how they react to the metal?
Yeah, he told me that we're only,
he'd only ever seen two other reactions.
Did he mention who reacted to the metal?
He didn't say.
He said, but it was nothing like what I saw here.
Yeah.
Well, you know, there's a story of Wernher von Braun
showing Uri Geller a piece of metal.
Right.
And he says, that's not from here.
Wernher von Braun takes me into his personal office.
There is a safe in the office.
He opens the safe.
I see a piece of metal.
I've never seen such a color.
Pulls it out.
It's not heavy.
Says, Uri, touch this.
Tell me what you feel now.
I put my hand on it and I say,
Wernher, this is not from here.
He says, you're right.
This is a piece of a UFO that crashed on our planet.
You know, I'm mind blown because as a child,
I used to sneak into movie theaters in Tel Aviv
to see films on extraterrestrial life.
And this is coming from the mouth of Wernher von Braun.
You're shot at that.
Exactly.
I saw some things about this metal.
In fact, I had a lot of photos
of it I had to delete.
They were classified, right?
But I've seen some of it in real time
on a litch on the microscope.
And what I saw, there were different types.
But it was moving.
The one piece, I have a picture,
where it looks like a universe swirling around and around
with all the galaxies and stuff inside.
That's what the metal, the piece from Zanesville,
cut that little sliver.
That's what it looked like.
Actually.
It was actually moving.
This other piece I saw was red.
It appeared red.
But it meant thousands of little blocks,
little square blocks,
and they were self-moving and stacking themselves.
They were moving in the material?
Well, they were slight replicating or something.
What?
They were moving in the material?
Yeah, this material is like living material.
And this is from Zanesville, or?
Well, it was a piece I saw.
I assume it was from Zanesville.
The piece, not the real Zanesville, but Zanesville.
The red, I don't know where that came from,
but the green, I'll show you the green.
What?
Yeah, I'll show you the,
I don't have the video of it, but I have a snapshot of it.
I wanna see that.
Yeah, I'll show it to you.
That is wild.
Yeah.
Wow.
Moving like a universe swirling around and around.
And the elements in that metal,
I was told it had 51 elements in it.
And the most classified, most,
we can only blend, at that time,
he told me about 15 elements.
Humans could only figure out how to make 15 elements blend.
But this had 51.
One of the elements was human DNA.
And he's like, how'd that get in there?
And plutonium, who puts plutonium in metal?
Wait, plutonium?
Human DNA was in this metal?
Yep.
And plutonium?
What?
And he's like, how?
How do they put human DNA in metal?
And then they figured out in zero gravity
how to bond ceramic to metal.
And then they were able to put human DNA into the ceramic.
And now your hip joints and all that,
they don't fail anymore.
Just all in our medical devices,
nobody realizes it as NASA's.
Cause my understanding is most manufacturing
and space initiatives haven't succeeded.
Like there's a company called Maidens,
and it was always this kind of academic project
and it never quite got off the ground.
But you could in zero G do all sorts of things
that you can't on the ground.
Right.
So, but you're saying there might be
some secret stuff going on.
Oh, sure.
Interesting.
Absolutely.
But they were able to bond ceramic to the metal
and human DNA into the ceramic.
But they couldn't do it.
Whoever did it, however it was done, we can't duplicate it.
Wow.
Well, Chris, this is a blast, man.
I love speaking to you.
And I think we could go on all day,
but there's so many threads I feel like I need to follow up on
just from this conversation alone.
So we'll have to run it back
and maybe I can come to Fayetteville.
I would love for you to.
That'd be a blast, man.
I appreciate it.
You should come.
In fact, maybe we get you to the coast, like on the beach.
Yeah.
For a couple of three nights
and we'll get a group there and blow your mind.
That sounds amazing.
Yeah.
Count me in.
Absolutely.
Thank you for coming to Austin, Texas on such short notice.
And I know you travel a ton.
And so just coming out here for a day really means a lot to me.
Believe it or not, in the last three weeks,
I left Fayetteville, North Carolina.
I went to Orange County, met with Sammy and a group of guys,
and then went up to Hollywood, met Margot Robbie
and some other people.
Left there, went back to North Carolina.
Dropped my wife off.
Flew back to New York, met some people there.
Took a train down to DC.
Met a whole group of, met Anna and some others there.
Then came home one day and I'm back here.
So it's been just burning the road up for three or four weeks.
And that's why I called you last night.
I was so exhausted.
I'm like, I'm tired.
I'm beat, Jesse.
So.
Or I'd have been here last night with you guys,
going to dinner or sky watching or something.
Yeah, no.
No worries.
Well, this was, this was really fun.
And now we'll, we'll do it again
and I'll come your way next time.
And that's a crazy schedule for somebody
who's already gone through all the stuff you've gone through.
So.
Don't end here.
It goes for the next 18 days.
I'm back to New York, to Pennsylvania, to DC,
and then to Wilmington for the World Forum.
And yeah, I want to make sure I plug the World Forum.
Okay.
What is that?
It's, it was created by McKill,
Gorbachev back in the 90s.
In 95 to 2000, it was a five year event
that ended up in New York City when they dropped the ball.
Bono was there, you two, they did the opening.
But it was the, the leaders of the world basically
all came together to talk about the Y2K,
because they thought the world was in trouble, right?
We had to have a conversation.
And so now for the next five years,
this year, until 2030,
they're going to convene the World Forum again
and it'll be
Abbey Love speaking,
Dr. Diana Hennessey-Powell,
and there's about 30 or 40, 31 speakers
and they'll be,
we were going to have it in DC at the Omni Shores this year,
but because of the travel and the flights and all,
so we can make it to the next,'
you the next himself.
gonna make it virtual this year and um i'll be speaking on there a time or two but my big thing
is on the 14th of the 15th 16th and 17th we're going to have a group down on the beach at
rightsville um about 40 of us doing a sky watch and we're going to broadcast it through the world
forum cool to the world yeah epic all right we'll go check that out by ufo of god and um yeah keep
keep checking out cool stuff that chris does and i really appreciate you being here man thank you
jesse for having me it's been too long it's been way too long long time coming but you know what
things happen in their time and i think there is the questions and the conversation we had this
time around is going to be you know it's much better than maybe what would have been a year
and a half ago absolutely
i've learned a lot since then and i've learned that i don't know anything right same with me
man the deeper i get the more i'm confused yeah i say it all the time the more i learn the less i
know right well that's that's literally true because if you think of your knowledge base
as say it's like a sphere um the sphere grows and then the the questions are the space around
the sphere right so the questions are going to grow at an exponent of
the space around the sphere so the questions are going to grow at an exponent of the space around
the sphere growing right and so you the more you know the more you know you don't know right and so
yeah i think the most knowledgeable people i know are the most epistemically humble and they're like
i don't know you know because he just gets more and more confusing it does like i say there's no
language for this so no each step you got to come up with something different you know yes but it's
like if you if you're getting if you're going into kind of higher dimensional spaces or like where
more information you do just have to have uh a better sensor like you know you need that you
need to be able to audit yourself better so as long as you can do that i learned that a long time
ago you know just admit you don't know you know don't label this thing and and i try not to and
because i can't tell you a hundred percent certain anything none of us can nobody can i can tell you
It's magical, it's been beautiful, and it's real.
And I'll leave it at that, and I can share it with others.
And if I can't, my children can.
Yeah.
They have it in them the same.
Do you think there have been any attempts
to censor you on any other media or podcast?
A lot.
So like how so?
Well.
And what's the motive?
And yeah, and what's an example and what's the motive?
I think that there's the narrative is it's dark and ugly
and evil, leave it alone.
Yeah, but you have such a positive healing story.
Well, and that's why.
And then, oh, they want it to be this like.
Dark and ugly, don't mess with it.
We might lose control of the people if you mess,
so they don't like me sharing this at all.
Mm, mm, it's very interesting.
I've been told that a thousand times.
Yeah.
I've been told two or three times,
you're doing disclosure.
Yeah.
Don't do, we're gonna do,
you're getting ahead of us.
Yeah.
Any examples of censorship that you've like.
Danny Jones.
Really?
That video and a whole lot more.
Which, what did Danny, oh, Danny Jones is,
the video's getting throttled performance wise.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, that was censorship.
That thing was going to 150,000 views a day.
What was it specifically that you think got it knocked?
That was me mentioning about some technology
at Mission Control.
Okay, okay.
Okay.
And I don't want to say that again.
Okay, sure, sure, sure, sure, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Got it, that's wild then.
Yeah.
And that's crazy, you backtrack, you kind of,
or back channeled and you figured out
that NASA was literally censoring.
Yeah.
Crazy.
Well, Google or whoever's controlling that.
Yeah, well, there's got to be connection there.
But they sent the word, that's what I was told.
There has to be a connection there.
It was about a technology.
Mm-hmm.
Yeah, I mean, Immaculate Constellation,
which came out in the Shellenberger testimony,
this November 2024 hearing,
Immaculate Constellation had like a search spike
when David Grush came out in, I think,
August or September of 2023.
So it's like, how do you, you can't make that up.
Right.
And if that's the case, that's like, you know.
It's kind of what happened.
That's what happened with me.
Interesting.
Yeah.
Yeah, and then I think there's a manipulation
of Google Trends because that then, this guy, Rob Jones,
who I've gotten to know a little better since then,
and seems very high trust, high credibility,
he found the spike and then the spike got deleted.
Yeah.
So it's like, if you're telling me that Google
doesn't have some sort of backdoor
around special access programs being named,
Yeah, yeah. They don't have a connection
with the DOD around that, you're crazy.
Absolutely.
You're the conspiracy theory.
Like, come on.
Yeah, and it happens to me all the time.
Yeah.
I would have sold twice as many books already,
guarantee you.
They've cost me a lot of book sales
because of shadow banning or, yeah.
Well, I think you're, I think it's piercing through.
I think, you know, a lot of people love your story
and are reading your book,
And, you know, whatever censorship may or may not be occurring, I don't think it's really, you know, hampering you in a serious way.
Right.
Well, we're pushing through.
There you go.
They can't keep the light out, right?
The light gets to cracks.
Yeah.
Well, that's this whole subject.
It's like, you know, don't take my, don't distrust everything I say or you say or anybody else.
But, like, the world is, I think, shifting in this sort of serious way.
And, like, you know, I fundamentally believe that.
And I see it and I feel it.
That's that new knowledge that's coming.
Yes.
Well, on that note, thank you so much, Chris.
I appreciate you, man.
Absolutely.
Thank you, brother.
Cool.
Absolutely.
All right.